GOOD MORNING WILL START AS A
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE FOLLOWING ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHORS --
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT TO FIVE
BELT STATE PRISONS PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AN ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY SIX PORTANTINO BURGLARY
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WE'RE READY BEGAN WE BEGIN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE ONE
AUTHORED READY TO GO AS USUAL AT
NINE O'CLOCK PROMPTLY ON TIME.
AND THAT SIZE SENATOR HILL S. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
TEN YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX INSURANCE THAT
STATE LAW KEEPS UP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S RAPID ADOPTION OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGIES.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS MADE IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX APPLIES THE
EXACT SAME POLICY IN PLACE. FOR
LICENSE PLATE READERS AND
CELLPHONE INTERCEPTED VICES TO
ALL SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY USED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE LICENSE PLATE READER INSULT
CELL PHONE INTERCEPTS DEVICE
LEGISLATION PASSED OFF OF OUR
FLOOR THIS THIS FOUR ACTUALLY
WITH BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IF THE POLICE WANT TO SEARCH
YOUR PHONE YOUR CAR OR YOUR
HOUSE THEY HAVE TO GET A WARRANT
BUT MANY AGENCIES HAVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT CONTRACT WHERE
YOU GO WHO YOU TALK.
TO AND WHAT YOU SAY IN PUBLIC
PLACES WITHOUT ANY SAFEGUARDS
OVER ONE HUNDRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE ARE
THOUGHT TO USE SOME TYPE OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY.
IN MANY DEPLOY MULTIPLE KINDS
INCLUDING FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY AND SOFTWARE THAT CAN
MONITOR SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES.
THIS MEANS SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE SUBJECT TO
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE AND LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW.
THE BILL PROVIDES AN EXIGENCY
COMPS DANCE PROVISION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ALLOW THEM TO USE
UNAPPROVED SURVEILLANCE DEVICES
IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS WILL ARGUE
THAT CREATING TRANSPARENCY
PROVIDES OF SURVEILLANCE ROADMAP
TO CRIMINALS.
THIS IS NOT THE CASE THE MERE
KNOWLEDGE OF A POLICE TACTIC
DOES NOT RENDER IT USELESS THERE
ARE ALREADY LAWS MANDATING THE
DISCLOSURE OF WIRE TAPS.
AND LICENSE PLATE READERS IN
BOTH TECHNOLOGIES STILL HELP
CATCH CRIMINALS SOME CONCERNS
MAY ALSO BE EXPRESSED BY THE
BREADTH OF SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES COVERED BY THIS
BILL.
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX RECOGNIZES
THE WIDE AND EVER CHANGING ARRAY
OF STUFF RIGHT SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES AT THE DISPOSAL OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE.
THE GOAL IS TO BE SPECIFIC
ENOUGH TO CAPTURE THE
APPROPRIATE SURVEILLANCE DEVICES
BUT NOT OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE SURE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO RUN A BILL
EACH YEAR.
AND EACH TIME A NEW TECHNOLOGIES
INVENTED.
INCLUSION OF LIKE TO MAKE ONE
THING VERY BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
USING SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY TO
FIGHT CRIME IT SIMPLY.
TAKES EXISTING STANDARDS FOR
LICENSE PLATE READERS AND
CELLPHONE INTERCEPT DEVICES AND
APPLIES THEM TO ALL SURVEILLANCE
DEVICES.
I SUPPORT USING TECHNOLOGY TO
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY BUT WE
NEED TO SAFEGUARD BASIC CIVIL
LIBERTIES FROM POTENTIAL ABUSES.
I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF
MEMBERS AND I'VE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE WITNESSES.
MORE IN THE NATURE MEMBERS KEVIN
BIG AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE
THAT LOCAL CONTROL THROUGH LOCAL
PUBLIC [inaudible]
SCHOOLS IS THE BEST WAY TO
ASSURE THE LOCAL VALUES AND
PRIORITIES ARE REFLECTED IN
THESE LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
DECISIONS.
AS SENATOR HILL INDICATED THIS
POWERFUL NEW TECHNOLOGIES MAY BE
GOOD AND USEFUL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEY ARE
CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE MANY CASES.
AND BUT WE SHOULD ALSO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THEY HAVE POTENTIAL
RISKS FOR INTRUSION INTO GUN.
PERSONAL PRIVACY OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE AND CAN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS HAD AND ACCESS TO
DATABASES WRONG FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUCH AS THE LICENSE
PLATE READER --
THAT IS USED TO TRACK PEOPLE'S
MOVEMENTS AND THE IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN USING THAT.
SUBSCRIBING TO THAT DATABASE AND
YET --
ACCORDING TO PUBLISHED REPORTS
AND YET WHEN THE ACLU HAS ASKED
FOR RECORDS.
REGARDING --
THAT -- I
PRACTICE ON THAT WE'VE BEEN
FORCED TO SUE ICE FOUND FOR
THEIR REFUSAL TO TURN OVER
INFORMATION ON THAT PROGRAM.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIAL FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PUBLIC TRUST.
VERY SIMILAR TO A BILL ON THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HEARD AND TO BY
MR GLORIA A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE WHICH THE COMMITTEE
PASSED A FEW WEEKS AGO.
REGARDING THE ACQUISITION USE OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT ALSO VERY
SIMILAR TO BUILD THE COMMITTEE
PASSED LAST YEAR SIN BY SENATOR
HILL SP TWENTY ONE EXCEPT THIS
BILL WAS EVEN NEAR WHERE --
AND WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
LOWER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
I RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX WE'VE HAD --
I CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
OR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON
THIS ISSUE --
ABOUT WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
CONTINUE OPPOSITION WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REQUIREMENT
AND THAT SHARE OF SUBMIT INITIAL
SURVEILLANCE POLICY UP FOR
APPROVAL.
AS WELL AS AMENDMENTS BASED ON
FUTURE TECHNOLOGY ACQUISITION
AND TO THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I AM.
SHERIFFS ARE AYE INDEPENDENT
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
RESPECTFULLY I'M SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN DATA APPROVAL
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
BEFORE DETERMINING HOW TO BEST
CARRY OUT THEIR DUTY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND IN FACT BY LIMITING THE
ABILITY OF THE SHERIFF TO
ACQUIRE SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
WITHOUT THE PRIOR CONSIDERATION
OF THAT POLICY BY THE BOARD S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX LIKELY
VIOLATES THE GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION.
TWENTY FIVE THREE OH THREE WHICH
STATES IN RELEVANT PART THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SHALL NOT
OBSTRUCT INVESTIGATIVE FUNCTION
OF THE SHERIFF OF THE COUNTY.
ARMS FORTIES REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TING
SHIPOWNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX AS WELL THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT HAVE A
LETTER ON FILE WITH COMMITTEE --
BUT WE DO HAVE AS SOME CONCERN
FOR THE BILL THAT WE'VE
EXPRESSED WITH THE AUTHOR WERE
PLEASED WITH THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD HOPEFULLY WILL RESOLVE
THOSE CONCERNS SOON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
JONATHAN WE MISSED THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF AND WE HAVE A CONFLICT.
WOULD BE FISCAL SECOND WEEK SO
IN ESTABLISH A CORE [inaudible]
CALL ROLE.
JONES SAWYER HERE.
LACKEY.
LEO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE UP [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
BOB PRESIDENT AND IF YOU GET
JUST BEAR WITH ME FOR A FEW MORE
OF WE HAVE TO CONSENT CALENDAR --
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE SIXTY
LEYVA DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION SUICIDE
PREVENTION REPORTS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. TANTON BELL.
PAROLEES SUPPORTIVE OFF HOUSING
PILOT PROGRAM.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT WILK SEX OFFENDERS
RISK ASSESSMENT ASSESSMENT
RESEARCH AND FINALLY ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN S. B..
NINETEEN I'M EFFING --
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY --
PUBLIC SAFETY OMNIBUS BILL MOVE
CONTENT CALENDAR.
ACTOR KALRA.
JONES SAWYER.
I JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
I CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAID CALORIES ADOPTED AND I DO
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES THE QUIRK.
SO I'VE DISCUSSES WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR --
SO I VOTED FOR AND EVEN HAD
BILLS OUT ASKING FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS IS THAT IT
IS JUST IT'S NOT DEFINING
[inaudible]
IN A JUST MUCH TO OPEN --
I WAS IN INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
IN FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND WE
ALWAYS WANT TO PROTECT SOURCES
AND METHODS.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE SOMETHING IS
COMPLETELY OPEN LIKE THIS
[inaudible]
WHERE?
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
TECHNOLOGY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT COULD BE THROUGH THIS
DISCLOSURE.
THAT YOU ARE GIVING--
NOTICE TO THE MORE SOPHISTICATED
MEMBERS OF THE CRIMINAL
COMMUNITY HOW TO AVOID --
ENFORCEMENT HOW TO AVOID
DETECTION --
IF THE BILL WHERE MORE NARROW I
THINK I COULD --
IF IT DISCUSSED PARTICULAR TYPE
OF TECHNOLOGY AND I VOTED.
FOR LIMITING --
ARE AT LEAST DISCLOSING THINGS
LIKE.
CAMBER READER AT LICENSE PLATE
READERS WITH CAMERAS.
DRONES AT CETERA BUT TO BE JUST
COMPLETELY OPEN LIKE THIS I
DON'T FEEL I CAN SUPPORT THE
BILL AT THIS TIME.
UP YOU CAN --
ANSWER ME IN YOUR CLOSE THANK
YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MR HILL WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU TO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK FOR A
FIRST QUESTION AND FOR OUR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
HAD -- YOU
KNOW IS A LOOK AT THE THE
LEGISLATION AND THE HISTORY OVER --
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY WHEN WE
STARTED WITH LICENSE PLATE
READERS AND THEN WE THE NEXT
YEAR WE ALL OF SUDDEN DISCOVERED
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAD BEEN
USING THE CELLULAR INTERCEPTED
VICES IN LOCATIONS THAT UP.
AND IN A MANNER THAT --
WASBASICALLY FOR A FREE FOR ALL
CIRCUMSTANCE ROUTE WITH NO
CONTROLS OVER IT AND EVEN ONE
CITY WAS USING IT DIDN'T FLY
[inaudible]
THAT A CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACED WITH IS THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS IS DEVELOPING SO
RAPIDLY THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR
US TO CONTINUOUSLY CONTINUALLY.
WAIT UNTIL WE GET SITE OF
UNDERSTAND HER SHE OR SOMEONE
EXPOSES A PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY --
AND THEN WE HAVE TO DO
LEGISLATION THIS COVERS ALL OF
THE LEGISLATION OR ALL OF THAT.
ANY NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
PRESENTED AND THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S PRESENTED --
WHAT WE'VE SEEN HISTORICALLY IS
IT DOESN'T?
PROJECT PRECLUDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM CATCHING THE BAD GUYS ARE
CRIMINALS JUST FOR THE FACT OF
HAVING IT OR THAT THE PUBLIC
KNOWS IT THEY KNOW WE DO
WIRETAPS TODAY.
THEY STILL TALK ON THE PHONE AND
SAY THE SAME THINGS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T THEY KNOW WE HAVE
LICENSE PLATE READERS IT PEOPLE
STILL STEAL CARS.
AND DRIVE AROUND IN THOSE CARS
AND GET PICKED UP FROM THEM --
THIS IS COMMON TECHNOLOGY THAT --
FROM ONE JURISDICTION TO THE
NEXT ISN'T SPECIFIC TO THAT
JURISDICTION FROM UP PERSPECTIVE
OF A OF A CRIMINAL AND THEY KNOW
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT IN THEY USE
THAT TECHNIQUE THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT USES THAT TECHNOLOGY.
I BELIEVE WITHOUT ANY
RESTRICTION TODAY AND AND IT'S
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
AND THAT'S THAT BUT TO ME THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART THAT THE
PUBLIC BODY THE ELECTED BODY THE
CIVILIAN BODY MAKES THOSE
DECISIONS AND UNDERSTANDS IN A
PUBLIC FORUM WHAT TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT IS BEING USED THEIR
EFFECT WE EFFORT I'VE OF MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
AT AND I RESPECT --
THAT THE QUESTION OF MISTER
CORCORAN AND I AND AND I'M.
WANNA MOVE THIS OUT SO WE CAN
KEEP THIS GOING I THINK --
TRANSPARENCY IS REALLY IMPORTANT --
IF YOU CAN WORK WITH.
THE COURT HOPEFULLY THAT THIS
BILL GETS OUT. TO TO TO ADDRESS
HIS CLAIM.
ARM BUT I DID WANT TO MENTION
[inaudible]
KIND OF TWO THINGS OF BECAUSE OF
HER JUST HAVE HEARD JUST A
SECOND TIME.
ON THIS QUESTION.
OF AUTHORITY.
OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY
[inaudible]
OVER --
LAFORTUNE.
BOB NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO DO THAT IS OUR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY --
SHERIFF COULD NOT FUND THEM
SELVES THIS YET NEARLY DONE BY
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY WE DO THAT
WITH CHP.
DO TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
WE DO THAT ON A LOCAL LEVEL
BOAST THAT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND
THE AND THE CITY LEVEL.
AND IN FACT --
DIFFICULT DEPARTMENTS CAN'T BE
FUNDED UNLESS THEY GET APPROVAL
FROM CITY COUNCIL NOT FROM THE
MAYOR.
NOT FROM THE SHERIFF NOTHING
CONTROL ENOUGH A TREASURE BUT
FROM.
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY WOULD THAT
BE COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS ARE
CITY COUNCIL SO THAT'S WE NEED A
LY THAT. TO THE SIDE.
ON TO WHEN IT COMES.
TO HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT OPERATES --
WE DON'T WANT TO GET INTO DEMAND.
A NEW SHOW HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATES A DIRT AS MR PARK SAID.
THERE'S SOMETHING SAID THE
PUBLIC PROBABLY SHOULD KNOW
ORDER [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
THERE BEEN TIMES WHERE TECHNIQUE.
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
ADVOCATED FOR FOR SOMETIME
CONTINUE TO DO IT DO IT HAVE
RESULTED.
IN SOME ADVERSE.
VERY EFFECTIVE AT KILLING MOSTLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALES.
BUT IT WASN'T.
ULTIMATELY WE STOPPED THAT IF WE
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY HAD NOT
INTERVENED.
THE MAYORS AND THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH HAD NOT INTERVENED.
THAT.
TECHNIQUE POLICY WILL PROBABLY
BE IN EFFECT TO NOW SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT HAVE SOME TYPE A
CITIZEN OVERSIGHT.
ON HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT OPERATES
ESPECIALLY FOR GOES WRONG.
IF THE PARTICULAR TECHNIQUES
ENDS UP WHERE --
WE HAVE THE UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT
AWARE ON AN OFFICER SHOOTS ANON
ARMED PERSON IN THE BACK.
THAT ITEM WE CAN LOOK AT THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES OF THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SEE
WHERE THERE'S A PROBLEM AND SO
THAT WE CAN CORRECT THAT
[inaudible]
OTHERWISE.
WHAT WILL WE HAD WE WOULD HAVE
ANYTHING AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT HAVE [inaudible]
NAM TRANSPARENCY.
SO THAT WE KNOW AND HAVE TRUST
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IT DID VALLEY
DOING THE RIGHT THING BUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS BASED.
ON ON ON THE ABILITY TO GET THE
JOB DONE KEEP LAW ENFORCEMENT
SAFE.
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
DEBT THAT WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IN THE MORAL THING.
AND WITH THAT I'M.
URGING THAT WE MOVED JUST
THROUGH.
I DO BELIEVE MISTER QUIRK HAS
SOME VALID ISSUES I HOPE.
HE ALLOWS YOU TO GET THROUGH
TODAY SO THAT WE CAN WORK
THROUGH THAT I THAT I DON'T LET
ANYONE.
TALK AFTER ME AND I'M LIKE SHUT
DOWN SOME.
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
INSIDE.
THIS ONE I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN
MOVE DECIDED HERE TODAY AND THAT
YOU WOULD WORK THANK YOU --
IT'S THERE A MOTION.
IS THERE A SECOND [inaudible]
CALDERON.
ON S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
IN LIEU OF THE REQUEST OF THE
CHAIR I WILL VOTE TO SEND THIS
OUT TODAY.
HOWEVER I RESERVE MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR AND BEGAN MIGHT MY PROBLEM
IS JUST THAT THIS IS SO OPEN
ENDED AND I'M WORRIED ABOUT
SOURCES AND METHODS WILL DISCUSS
IT LATER WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
PARK I SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND THEY COULDN'T CARE THANK YOU
MEMBERSHIP IN.
AND PLEASE WORK WITH MISTER
QUIRK I I WILL IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE RAIMES WORK WITH
MISTER QUIRK.
SO I SEE FOUR EMPTY CHAIRS SO
I'M LOOKING.
FOR MISTER BRADFORD WHO SIGNED
IN MISTER WILK AND WIENER.
BRADFORD WELCOME WIENER AND I
HAVEN'T HAD ANY OTHER SCIENCE SO
SIGNAL HAVE A VERY SHORT.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING
[inaudible]
EXTENSIVE [inaudible]
YEAH THAT [inaudible]
TROYER.
HELLO MISTER BRADFORD YOU MAY.
TAKE YOUR SEAT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY YOU COULD BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
SIMPLY WILL HOLD.
CLARIFY CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX
LAWS AS A RICH AND RESTORE
GREATER PROPORTIONALITY
[inaudible]
AND ARE.
A JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHAT ARE PAST EFFORTS ON THE WAR
ON DRUGS AND ARE TOUGH?
ON CRIME MENTALITY FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE NATION AND STATE.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVASTATING
THEN TARGET A TIRE COMMUNITIES
PART PRIMARILY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
AN OVERCROWDED OUR PRISON SYSTEM --
BEYOND --
HUMAN.
COMPREHENSION.
AND MUCH IS IS BEING CAUSED BY
ARE VERY COMPLEX AND ARCHAIC
SENTENCING LAWS --
WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
CONFUSING SENTENCING LAWS IN THE
NATION EVEN SO THAT.
ALL LAWYERS AND JUDGES COSTUMES
STATE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
THIS BILL WOULD --
NOT SCRIPT AND I MEAN INCLUDES
BUT NOT LIMITED TO BASED TERMS
PRINCIPLE TERM SUBORDINATE TERMS
AGGREGATED TERMS ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING SCHEMES CONCURRENT
SENTENCING.
THE TERMINATE AND TURN
INDETERMINATE SENTENCING AND OF
COURSE HUNDREDS OF SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS WHICH ADD YEARS TO
OUR RADIO HARSH AND LONG PRISON
TERM.
WALKED AMEND THE GOVERNOR IN OUR
STATE EFFORTS TO LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF CRIMES THAT WE NOW
ENACT THE INTRICATE WEB OF
SENTENCING LAWS.
AS I STATE IT CONFUSES JUDGES
AND LAWYERS TO ADD TO THE
PROBLEM OF COMPLEXITY IT'S
UNCERTAIN IF WHAT THE SENTENCES
SERVE -- ADS
ARE INTENDED FUNCTION TO DIG TO
YOUR CRIME IF YOU WERE TO LOOK
AT THE STATISTICS WOULD OFF.
EASILY UP TO SAY THAT THEY DON'T
ARE CRIME --
BASED ON SOME FOLKS HAVE
INCREASED OVER THE NUMBER OF THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS SO IT
CLEARLY APPROVES AT THESE LONG
SENTENCES --
SENTENCING AYE TERMS HAVE NOT
DISSUADE OR DISCOURAGE FOLKS
FROM ARE COMMITTING CRIME UNTIL
WE CAN PROVE INCARCERATION WORKS
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE SHOULD
DOLE OUT EXTREME SENTENCES FOR
ALL CASES IN WHICH SENTENCE
ENHANCES MAYBE LONGER.
THAN THE UNDERLYING FELONY
SENTENCE THE STOP A POLICIES DO
NOT IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
INSTEAD CONTRIBUTOR GENERATIONAL
SICK CYCLE OF CRIMES AND
VIOLENCE AMONGST FAMILIES ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WILL
HELP SAVE ONE IS CONVOLUTED
SENTENCE LAWS IMPROVE IMPROVE.
THE BALANCE BETWEEN ENHANCEMENTS
AND UNDERLYING FELONIES BY
SIMPLY ENSURING THAT A FULL TERM
OF IMPRISONED DOES NOT EXCEED
TWICE THE NUMBER OF YEARS OF
THAT BASE TERM.
WITH ME TODAY IS EXPERT STEVE
RIES.
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROFESSOR OF EVIDENCE AT
MODERATE COLLEGE WHO LAW
INFORMER ATTORNEY OF MONTEREY
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
AND ALSO CHUCK DENTON ARE A
LECTURE AT UC BERKELEY AN
ATTORNEY WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY.
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND
WITH THAT --
HOMES CHAIR MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM STEVEN RACE I'M ATTORNEY IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE NOW I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING COULD THE DEFENSE
BOSSES.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND I'M
ALSO WAS PARENTS ABOUT A CENTER
BRADFORD SAID CURRENTLY
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE --
AT THIS BILL.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE REALLY SEEKS
TO BRING SOME COMMON SENSE AND A
CERTAIN.
SIMPLICITY TO SENTENCING LAW IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS IT CURRENTLY EXISTS THE
CALIFORNIA SENTENCING LAW IS A
MAZE OF CODE.
SECTIONS WITH WIDE RANGING BASED
TERMS PRINCIPLE TERM SUBORDINATE
TERMS AND MULTIPLE ENHANCEMENTS.
SOME OF WHICH CAN BE IMPOSED IN
SOME SITUATIONS BUT NOT IN OTHER
SITUATIONS --
THERE ARE.
NUMEROUS BOOKS WRITTEN ON
SENTENCING LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT RUN HUNDREDS OF PAGES THERE
ARE ALL DAY SEMINARS SOMETIMES
MORE THAN ONE DAY SEMINARS THAT
ARE PROVIDED TO JUDGES LAWYERS
PROBATION OFFICERS --
ABOUT HOW DO SENTENCING
CORRECTLY IN THE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO --
AS SPEND SOME OF OUR TIME
READING APPELLATE DECISIONS --
WE SEE FREQUENTLY CASES BEING
SENT BACK TO THE TRIAL COURT TO
RE SENTENCE ARE DEFENDANTS ARE
BECAUSE THERE WAS AN ERROR POT.
NO INTENT NO BAD FAITH JUST AN
ERROR IN CALCULATING THE
DEFENDANT'S SONS.
THOSE RETURNS BECAUSE OF
SENTENCING COMPLICATIONS AND
ERRORS COST THE STATE UP.
I'M CREDIBLE AMOUNT OF MONEY
HAVE THOSE CASES SET BACK AND RE
DONE -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS BILL HAS --
SIGNIFICANT EXCEPTIONS TO THE
DOUBLE BASS TERM LIMIT.
THEIR SPELLED OUT.
IN THE STATUTE.
AND WHAT IS NOT COVERED UNDER
THIS LIMITATION ON DOUBLE BASS
TERM.
ARE SOME OF THE MORE --
SIGNIFICANT OR SERIOUS CRIMES
GANG CRIMES HUMAN SEX
TRAFFICKING.
AGGRAVATED SEXUAL ASSAULT UPON --
A CHILD HA HABITUAL CRIMINAL --
ENHANCEMENTS FELONY STRIKE
ENHANCEMENTS SEX CRIMES WITH A
CHILD WITH HIS A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR SEX CRIME --
RAPE --
CASES WHERE THERE IS EITHER A
SINGLE VICTIM WITH COST%
[inaudible]
MULTIPLE --
I TAX OR MULTIPLE VICTIMS --
WITH MULTIPLE ATTACKS IN THE
FIRST SCENARIO THE COURT --
MAY IMPOSE WHAT.
LAWYERS CALL A FULL BOAT CONSENT.
MEANING THE THE SECOND OFFENSE
IS SATIN'S --
EXACTLY AS THE FIRST OFFENSE AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT.
WE CALL ONE THIRD THE MIDDLE
TERM.
WHEN THE SITUATION APPLIES WHERE
THERE'S MULTIPLE VICTIMS OR A
SINGLE VICTIM IN MULTIPLE
ATTACKS?
THE COURT MUST IMPOSE THE FULL
CONSECUTIVE TERM SO.
A SIX YEAR RAPE CASE SECURE
CONVICTION WITH A SECOND SIX
YEAR CONVICTION BECOMES A TWELVE
YEAR.
CONVICTION --
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS FOR THE
THREE STRIKES LAW TOWN SENDS
INVOLVING A THREE STRIKES
CONVICTION WOULD NOT BE COVERED.
UNDER --
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE AND
KIDNAPPING OF A CHILD WITH
INTENT TO PROBABLY DEPRIVE.
WOULD NOT BE COVERED UNDER THIS
SO THAT THE AUTHOR HAS MADE SOME
VERY.
SERIOUS AND NUANCED.
EFFORTS.
TO HOW THE STATUTE APPLIED TO
THE MORE BASIC FELONY OFFENSES
THAT OCCUR.
IN THE STATE AND STILL WE LIVE
THE THE JUDGES WITH THE
DISCRETION TO IMPOSE MORE.
IN CLOSING I WOULD TAKE YOU BACK
TO THE CASE THAT OVER.
THAT SET THIS IN MOTION PEOPLE
VERSUS MCGILL BACK IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX ON THE PART
OF MCGILL I ASK YOU TO PAY
ATTENTION.
TO IS FOOTNOTE.
FOR WHEN THE COURT RICH RENDERED
ITS DECISION THAT THE DOUBLE
BASS TERM LAW WAS --
NOT AT YOUR FOUR MINUTES.
NOT LEAVE THEM MUCH TIME OUTSIDE
ALL I ASK YOU DO ON IS TO FOLLOW
THE OLD QUOTE FROM JUSTICE
FRANKFURTER THAT WISDOM TOO
pTO REJECTED BECAUSE IT COMES
LATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAY BEGIN SIR --
YES SENATOR BRADFORD DESCRIBE
CALIFORNIA SENTENCING AS ONE OF
THE MOST COMPLEX IN THE NATION I
THINK THAT KIND OF UNDER CELLS A
LITTLE BIT --
I TOOK AN INFORMAL POLL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF LAW.
AND THE CONSENSUS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SENTENCING SCHEME
IS BY A GOOD MEASURE THE MOST
COMPLEX IN THE NATION.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE AMONG OTHER
THINGS IT'S GOT ABOUT FIVE
DIFFERENT LAYERS WHO COMPLEXITY.
MOST OTHER STATES HAVE ONE OR
TWO PLAYERS WE HAVE --
FIVE AND I'M IN THE LIMITED TIME
HAVE I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE PRACTICAL EFFECT
OF THIS --
ABOUT A MONTH AGO I GOT A LETTER.
FROM THE CDC ADDRESS TO THE MOST
SENIOR AND PROBABLY THE MOST
SCHOLARLY JUDGE IN OUR COUNTY.
ASKING HIM TO CORRECT THE LEGAL
HEIR THAT HE MADE IN THE SENSE.
AND I WENT OVER TO THE
COURTHOUSE TO LOOK ATTHE COURT
FILE AND I WHEN I DID I REALIZE
THAT THIS LETTER WAS JUST.
THE LAST IN A SERIES OF LETTERS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS ASKING TO CORRECT
THIS ERROR.
WHICH HE REFUSED TO TAKE ANY
ACTION ON IT INSISTING THAT HE
WAS RIGHT AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WHICH
ACTUALLY WAS RIGHT IN THIS CASE
WAS WRONG.
SO I WAS CURIOUS I ASKED THE
CLERK TO GET A LOT OF THESE
LETTERS.
AND SHE SAID WELL I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU MEAN BY A LOT.
SO THAT KIND OF PIQUED MY
CURIOSITY SO I I EMAILED THE
PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICER AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
AND I ASKED HIM HOW MANY OF
THESE LETTERS DO YOU SEND OUT.
SO EMAIL ME BACK HE SAYS IS
INTERESTING YOU ASK THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
BEEN ASKING THE SAME QUESTION.
ANY SAID WE WE SENT OUT A COUPLE
HUNDRED OF THESE IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS.
AND APPARENTLY IN THE REVISED
BUDGET FOR THIS YEAR THERE'S TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO BOLSTER THE
FOR THIS UNIT --
THAT EXPLORE SENTENCE
DISCREPANCIES.
SO THAT'S THAT'S GOOD THE JUDGES
THE LAWYERS I LOOKED AT SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION AND I TRIED TO DO
THE NUMBERS AND I DON'T GET
ANYWHERE NEAR THE NUMBERS THAT
THEY GET.
AND I THAT'S I MEAN I'M RIGHT NO
WRONG I DON'T KNOW THAT IT DOES
AFTER THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF DOING
THIS THE ONE THING I KNOW. FOR
SURE ABOUT SENTENCING IS THAT
NOTHING CERTAIN.
AND I MAYBE WRONG THERE MAY BE
SOME OBSCURE SENTENCING RULER
ENHANCEMENT BURIED DEEP IN THE
PENAL CODE.
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE POINT
THAT WHEN YOU WRITE THESE LAWS
YOU EXPECT THEM TO BE.
EXECUTED IN UNIFORM A
PROPORTIONAL MANNER AND YOU
EXPECT THEM TO HAVE SOME
DETERRENT EFFECT.
BUT IF THE SENIOR AND SCHOLARLY
JUDGE CAN'T GET IT RIGHT IF
LAWYERS ON BOTH SIDES CAME TO
GET THE ARITHMETIC RIGHT.
THEN HOW CAN YOU EXPECT THE LAWS
YOU ENACT.
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN A UNIFORM
A PROPORTIONAL MANNER.
AND OF WE DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
CAN YOU EXPECT.
THE AVERAGE CITIZEN.
THE HAVE ANY DETERRENT EFFECT ON
THIS.
THIS BILL IS NOT GONNA SWING
OPEN THE PRISON GATES.
IT'S NOT GONNA SAN RECIDIVISM
RATES SOARING AND IT'S NOT GONNA
PREVENT JUDGES FROM STRICTLY
PUNISHING.
SERIOUS VIOLENT AND SEX OFFENSES
BUT IT IS THE FIRST STEP.
IN UNTANGLING IN SIMPLIFYING.
WHAT IS THE MOST COMPLEX AND
FRUSTRATING SENTENCING LAWS IN
THE NATION AND THAT'S WHAT HAS
MY SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER [inaudible]
ARE.
IS THERE AND THE THERE FLOOR ARE
NOT OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING.
TO MATTHEWS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THE PRACTICAL EFFECT OF SP
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE IS TO GIVE A
VOLUME DISCOUNT TO CRIMINALS WHO
VICTIMIZE FOR A MORE INDIVIDUALS.
OR THOSE WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE
SUBJECT TO A SIGNIFICANT HANSON
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE
CONSIDER SOMEONE CONVICTED OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WITH SIX
VICTIMS.
LET'S ASSUME THAT THE JUDGE
IMPOSED THE LOWER TERM OF FIVE
YEARS FOR THE PRINCIPLE TERM.
AND SENTENCED THE DEFENDANT
CONSECUTIVELY FOR THE OTHER FIVE
VICTIMS FOR TOTAL SENTENCE OF
EIGHTEEN YEARS FOUR MONTHS.
UNDER S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE FOR THIS
DEFENDANT WOULD BE CAPPED AT
DOUBLE THE BASE TERM OR TEN
YEARS.
THAT'S ALMOST A 50% SENTENCE
REDUCTION AND EFFECTIVELY GIVE
THE DEFENDANT THREE FREE VICTIMS.
VIOLENT OFFENDERS ARE THE MOST
LIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM THIS.
AS NON VIOLENT OFFENDERS ARE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
AFTER SERVING JUST THE PRINCIPAL
TAM.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
COMPROMISES THE RIGHTS OF CRIME
VICTIMS TO RECEIVE JUSTICE AND
JEOPARDIZES THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
YES THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BUT I'M
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOMAR
TOKAT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SENTENCING STATUTES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ARE EXTENSIVE BUT
THEY ARE NOT INDECIPHERABLE TO
THE PROSECUTORS THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS AND THE JUDGES WHO
WORK WITH THEM EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IN FACT THE MAXIMUM THAT A
DEFENDANT FACES ON EVERY CASE IS
DETERMINED.
IN EACH CASE BY THE PROSECUTORS
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AND THE JUDGES
WHO HANDLE THESE CASES THIS IS
NOT ROCKET SCIENCE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WHEN YOU DO IT
FOR A LIVING.
YOU LEARN IT AND YOU DO IT
CORRECTLY OF COURSE THERE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE HUMAN ERROR.
HUMAN ERROR HAPPENS IN EVERY
SCENARIO IN LIFE BUT JUST
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE HUMAN
ERROR DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE GET
RID OF A BOTH A PROCESS THAT
WORKS.
IN FACT THE CURRENT SENTENCING
LAWS SERVED A VERY IMPORTANT
PURPOSE THEY DIFFERENTIATE THE
PERSON WHO USES A GUN FROM THE
PERSON WHO DOES NOT USE A GUN
DURING THE COMMISSION OF AN
OFFENSE.
THE CURRENT LAWS DIFFERENTIATE
THE PERSON WHO SERIOUSLY INJURES
A HUMAN BEING DURING THE
COMMISSION OF OF AN OFFENSE FROM
THE PERSON WHO DOES NOT CAUSE
GREAT BODILY INJURY.
THE CURRENT LAW DIFFERENTIATES
THE PERSON WHO COMMITS ONE CRIME
AGAINST ONE VICTIM FROM THE
PERSON THAT COMMITS MULTIPLE
CRIMES AGAINST MULTIPLE VICTIMS.
THAT'S WHAT THE CURRENT LAWS ARE
THEREFORE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAPPEN
WITHIN A CRIME AND NOT TO TREAT
EVERYBODY EXACTLY THE SAME WAY.
THIS BILL HAS NO EXCEPTIONS FOR
GUN USE WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA AND
SPEAKING FOR LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
A HUGE PROBLEM WITH GUN VIOLENCE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THIS BILL ALSO DOES NOT MAKE AN
EXCEPTION FOR A CAUSING GREAT
BODILY INJURY OR FOR HAVING
MULTIPLE VICTIMS ROUTINELY IN
LOS ANGELES WE SEE.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMIT ARMED
ROBBERIES AGAINST MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUAL SOMETIMES IN ONE
NIGHT BY WAY OF EXAMPLE WE ONCE
PROSECUTED ARE FOR A DEFENDANT
WHO COMMITTED FIVE SEPARATE
ARMED ROBBERIES IN ONE NIGHT.
AGAINST EIGHT DIFFERENT VICTIMS
ONE OF THE VICTIMS WAS AN
ELDERLY WOMAN THAT HE SHOVED TO
THE GROUND BREAKING ONE OF HER
LIMBS.
UNDER THIS BILL THE JUDGE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE GREAT BODILY
INJURY ALL OF THE OTHER ICTIMS
WHERE HE POINTED A GUN IN THEIR
FACES TOLD THEM HE WAS GOING TO
KILL THEM.
BECAUSE THERE'S GOING TO BE A
CAP UNDER THIS BILL IF IT WERE
TO PASS THE MAXIMUM THAT PERSON
WOULD GET IS TEN YEARS WHEN
REALLY HE SHOULD BE FACING WELL
OVER.
THIRTY FIVE FOR ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT VICTIMS ALL OF THE
TIME TO USE THE GONE ALL OF THE
TIMES THAT HE COULD HAVE FIRED
THAT GUN WHAT IF ONE OF THE
VICTIMS HAD ACTUALLY JUMPED UP
AND TRIED TO TAKE THE GUN AWAY.
THAT HAPPENS THEN PEOPLE DIE AND
THAT'S WHY THE CURRENT
SENTENCING STATUTES RE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS.
AND IMAGINE AND EVEN THOUGH THE
BILL HAS EXCEPTIONS FOR OF MANY
SEX CRIMES IT DOESN'T COVER
EVERY SEX CRIME.
IT A COACH OR A TEACHER WHO
MOLESTS MULTIPLE FOURTEEN OR
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS IS NOT GOING
TO GET CONSECUTIVE SENTENCING
UNDER THIS BILL THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CAP OF SIX YEARS FOR
MOLESTING.
MULTIPLE FIFTEEN OR FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD SO YOU MIGHT AS WELL GO
AHEAD AND MOLEST THIRTY OTHERS
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
PUNISHED FOR IT [inaudible]
SHOOTINGS.
IF YOU END UP SHOOTING AT
MULTIPLE PEOPLE WITH THE INTENT
TO KILL ASSUMING THERE'S NO --
DELIBERATION OR PREMEDITATION SO
IT'S NOT A LIFE OFFENSE.
THE MULTIPLE SHOOTINGS WILL GET
THE SAME SENTENCE AS THOUGH YOU
SHOT AT ONE PERSON UNDER THIS
BILL.
LAST YEAR OUR FIREARMS
ENHANCEMENTS BECAME
DISCRETIONARY FOR THE JUDGE IN
IN FACT THAT WAS SENATOR
BRADFORD'S BILL.
BUT NOW IF THIS BILL WERE TO
BECOME LAW JUDGES WHO WANT TO
IMPOSE A FIREARMS ENHANCEMENT IN
A PARTICULAR CASE BECAUSE IS THE
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO.
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
AND EVEN IF THEY DID IF YOU
REACH A CERTAIN CAP IF YOU REACH
A CERTAIN CAP YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO IMPOSE IT BECAUSE
HEY WE RUN OUT OF NUMBERS
BECAUSE IT'S MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE BASED TERM THAT'S TAKEN.
THE PUNISHMENT SHOULD ALWAYS FIT
THE CRIME.
BUT THAT ALSO REQUIRES THAT WE
NOT FORGET THE INNOCENT VICTIMS
OF CRIME VICTIMS OF CRIME
DESERVE JUSTICE AND SIMPLIFYING
MATHEMATICS AND GETTING RID OF A
THE THEREFORE THEIR SUFFERING.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE ALL THESE
MULTIPLE VICTIMS IMAGINE YOU
HAVE A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD KID AND
YOU SAY TO THAT COULD YOU KNOW
WHAT THE PERSON WHO MOLESTED YOU.
I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT GOING GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SENTENCE THAT
PERSON FOR YOUR MOLESTATION
BECAUSE YOU HAPPEN TO BE KID
NUMBER FIVE YOU HAPPEN TO BE KID
NUMBER SIX THAT IS NOT JUSTICE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN DEMOING US THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE ASSOCIATION OPPOSITIONS
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
MY COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE IS SHOWN MUCH LOWER ON
THE AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
PARDEE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SUPPORT --
FIRST MISTER BRADFORD COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE ARGUMENT FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVE.
OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF LA
ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO PUNISH
PEOPLE --
FOR MOLESTATION.
I I REALLY WANT YOU IF I CAN
STOP LAUGHING AT THE COMICAL
PRESENTATION THAT I JUST LISTEN
TO I MEAN.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST.
GROSS MIS REPRESENT
REPRESENTATIONS OF THE PIECE OF
EIGHT YEARS OF BEING HERE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE IT'S FICTIONAL
AT BEST.
PEOPLE WHO COMMIT SEX CRIMES
WILL STILL BE CONVICTED FOR
THOSE SEX CRIMES EVEN THEN USING
OF A GUN IT DOESN'T STRIKE ANY
OF THAT OUT OF THAT.
ANY SHE MADE TO REFERENCE TO GUN
ENHANCEMENTS I PASSED A BILL
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT
ON JUDICIAL DISCRETION ON GUN
ENHANCEMENT BENNETT HAPPENS
DON'T GO AWAY YOU JUST GIVE THE
JUDGE'S DISCRETION AT SENTENCING
TIME.
SEEM ASK HERE YOU HAVE TO BE A
MATHEMATICIAN TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH TIME SOMEONE GETS ARE.
BASED ON OUR CURRENT ALL A
SENTENCING LAW SHOW.
I I'M PANEL LOSS --
A DOCTOR QUIRK BECAUSE I I'M
INSULTED BY THAT PRESENTATION
BECAUSE IT TOTALLY REPORT RE I
MISS REPRESENTS EVERYTHING THAT
THIS THE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AYE AYES IS INTENDING TO DO.
HERE TO SIMPLIFY IT'S NOT TO LET
ANYONE OUT OF JAIL IT'S NOT TOO
WELL ABOUT A WEEK IN OUR OUR
SENTENCING LAWS WHATSOEVER.
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
IT STILL GIVES THE JUDGE AND THE
PROSECUTOR THE SAME TO ALL WERE
JUST SEEN WHEN YOU SENTENCE
SOMEBODY WHEN WE WE MAKE IT WHAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
WELL BETTER ARGUMENT WAS --
IF.
AT SOME LOWER LEVEL I'M NOT
QUITE SURE.
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN THIS INVITE
ISN'T BUT IF YOU MOLESTED SOME
LOWER LEVEL --
SHE USED A TEACHER EXAMPLE TO
CRIMES RATHER THAN FIVE I MEAN I
I DON'T UNDERSTAND YOUR BILL
WELL ENOUGH NOW. TO YOUR EXPERTS
ARE SAYING NOW TELL ME.
SPECIFIC EXCEPTION COULD CLOSE
TO LIKE.
THERE'S A SPECIFIC EXCEPTION FOR
SIX SIX SEVEN POINT SIX WHICH
ALLOWS FOR CONSECUTIVE
SENTENCING FOR FORCIBLE ANY SORT
OF FORCIBLE MOLESTATION IMPACT.
AND WHAT ABOUT --
FIVE ARMED ROBBERIES IN ONE
NIGHT.
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU GO TO DOUBLE
WHAT IT IS FOR NON BRIBERY OR
WOULD YOU DO IF THE YOU YOU WILL
DOUBLE THE BASE TERM SO IF THE
JUDGE SAYS OKAY ARMED ROBBERY
THE MAXIMUM SENTENCES.
TAKE TEN YEARS YOU GET TWENTY
YEARS FOR THAT.
THAT'S NOT A LIGHT SENTENCE AT
ALL.
YOU GET TWENTY YEARS FOR THAT SO
WHATEVER THAT SENTENCES WERE
SEEN DOUBLE THAT.
AND AYE NW SHOULD EXPECT TO DO
MORE THAN THAT BASED ON THE
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED WERE
SAYING DOUBLE THAT BASED TERM SO
WE EVEN TO JUDGE USE.
THAT -- THE
MINIMUM SENTENCING --
THE MIDDLE RANGE OR THE MAXIMUM
RANGE WE SEE DOUBLE THAT
[inaudible]
BASED BASIS YEAH I AGREE THAT.
A PEOPLE DON'T CALCULATE WHAT
THE TERM IS GOING TO BE WHEN
THEY GO OUT AND COMMIT A CRIME.
YEAH SO THAT I DON'T SEE THE
DETERRENCE VALUE FURTHER FOR
SOMEBODY'S BEEN IMPRISONED
TWENTY YEARS.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT PERSON
COMING OUT TYPICALLY THESE ARE
DONE BY YOUNG MAN AND I GONNA
TALK ABOUT MIDDLE AGED MAN.
SO I DON'T SEE THE POINT IN
KEEPING THE MEN FOR THESE VERY
LONG TIMES.
NOR BUT MAYBE YOU AND I COULD
WORK TOGETHER ON GETTING RID OF
SOME OF THIS COMPLEXITY SO
INSTEAD OF FIVE LAYERS LAYERS
THERE'S CHIU.
OR WHATEVER RATHER THAN --
THIS APPROACH WHICH I AGREE WITH
THEM IN FACT I'D LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
HOW BECAUSE I THINK TOO MANY
PEOPLE END UP IN JAIL FOR TO LOG?
AND IT'S NOT A DETERRENT WAY AND
TO KEEP SOMEBODY AND YEARS
INSTEAD A TWENTY BUT THE
COMPLEXITY SOUNDS LIKE A REAL
ISSUE AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF LA IT
SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE DO MAKE
MISTAKES.
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO GET RID
OF THAT AND PERHAPS YOU AND I
COULD WORK TOGETHER ON IT NEXT
YEAR HAVING SAID THAT.
I DON'T THINK THE BILL IS BEEN
MOVED SO LET ME MOVE THE BELL
THANK YOU.
AB MISTER LACKEY HAS A QUESTION
OR COMMENT.
YEAH CERTAINLY BOTH --
CENTER BRADFORD I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR YOU SELECT SO PLEASE
DON'T TAKE MY COMMENTS AS AN
INSULT BUT I AFTER COLLEGES LACY
IT.
AND I LIKE TO ASK --
LARA DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
CLARIFY THE CLAIM [inaudible]
AND TO ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU USED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT DAY IS NOT INCLUDED AND
SIXTY OR SIX SIX SEVEN POINT SIX
IS NOT CORRECT.
I WAS REFERRING TO TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT C. WHICH IS A QUALITY
NATION OF A FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD --
CHILD MOLESTATION ISN'T
NECESSARILY ALWAYS FORCIBLE SO
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
FORCEABLE RAPE ABOUT.
IT'S IT'S A VERY DELICATE
SUBJECT AND THEY ARE OF KIDS CAN
BE MOLESTED WITHOUT BEING FORCED
INTO IT IN OTHER WORDS I THINK
WE'VE SEEN THAT --
PLAY OUT EVEN IN THE NEWS VERY
RECENTLY WITH THE YOU KNOW THE
OLYMPICS COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE
OF EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED. TO
THOSE GIRLS --
IS NOT NECESSARILY FORCIBLE BUT
IT HAPPENS AND IF THEY'RE
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS OLD IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
C. AND UNDER --
THIS BILL THE MAXIMUM OF FOR THE
BASE TERM IS THREE YEARS SO IF
YOU DOUBLED UP THAT SIX YEARS SO
IF YOU MOLEST THIRTY KIDS FORTY
KIDS WHO ARE FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD.
YES YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO GET SIX
YEARS FOR THAT AND THERE'S GOING
TO BE GOOD TIME --
CREDITS FOR THAT AS WELL SO
YOU'RE NOT IN --
SIX YEARS AND CERTAINLY I DON'T
SEE THAT IS LAUGHABLE IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM.
I THINK THAT --
THERE THERE WOULD BE SOME VERY
SERIOUS INJUSTICES TO VICTIMS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT TIMES.
TIME MEANT AND REHABILITATION
BUT THERE COMES A POINT TO WHERE
SOME OF THESE CRIMES ARE BEING
CONVICTED.
ARE MORE THAN JUST.
LAPSES OF JUDGMENT WHEN MAKING
IT SOUND LIKE IT'S SOMEBODY --
MAKING THE CHOICE TO DRIVE TO
FASTER.
NO WE HAVE VICTIMS THAT ARE.
IMPACTED BY SOMEONE IS CRIMINAL
OF BEHAVIORS FOR THEIR LIVES.
THEY GET NO RELIEF FROM FROM
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO BE VERY VERY
CAREFUL --
IN.
AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO SERVE
VICTIMS AS WELL AS PERPETRATORS
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT ANYMORE COMMENT.
YES --
SENATOR BRADFORD MAYBE YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES CAN SPEAK TO
THIS I HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES.
TO SEX CRIMES BUT MAYBE MORE
GENERALLY.
IF YOU COMMIT ONE OF THESE
CRIMES MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THEY'RE STACKABLE --
IN TERMS OF THE SENTENCING IS
THAT TRUE ANSWER.
THAT THEY'RE STACKABLE.
SENTENCING SO MAY BE ONE OF THE
LAWYERS COULD SPEAK TO THIS YEAR
FOR INTO SEX OFFENSES IN HIM YES
UNDER SIX SIX SEVEN POINT.
SIX THEY'RE FULLY STACKABLE THAN
IT DOES INCLUDE.
A LEWD AND LASCIVIOUS ACTS WITH
A CHILD UNDER TO EIGHTY EIGHT BE
IT ALSO INCLUDES CONTINUOUS
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WITH A CHILD
UNDER. TO EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE IN THOSE ARE FULL TERM
STACKING SO OF FORCIBLE MOST OF
MY THREE YEARS SIX YEARS EIGHT
YEARS.
SHE COULD GO [inaudible] EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT AND ITSELF AND
I'M SORRY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THAT
ADDS UP DOESN'T IT YES IT.
VERY QUICKLY
VERY QUICKLY I'M SORRY IF I
INTERRUPTED YOU DID YOU WANNA
FINISH WHAT YOU WERE SAYING
AHEAD WITH.
THIS [inaudible]
WE ACCEPTED.
WHAT THE EXEMPTION UNDER SIX SIX
SEVEN POINT SIX COULD YOU SAY
THAT AGAIN IN THE MICROPHONE?
THE THE DOUBLE BASS TERM IS
SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTED UNDER.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE UNDER SIX
SIX SEVEN POINT SIX AND SECTION
TWO ELEVEN SEVENTY POINT ONE A
AYE TO IN THE BILL.
THAT'S WILL REFER.
AND CAN I ADD THAT IF IT'S UNDER
CERTAIN SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
LEWD LASCIVIOUS ACTS CARRIES A
LIFE SENTENCE.
UNDER SIX SIX SEVEN POINT.
SIX ONE THANK YOU SO SENATOR
BRADFORD AYE I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR YOU.
IS THE INTENT OF THIS BILL TO
LET EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO GETS
CONVICTED OUT.
NO I I MEAN IT'S THAT'S THE MOST
RIDICULOUS DOES REFERENCE HERE
WERE ALL ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HERE IT'S NOT A SINGLE PERSON IN
THIS BUILDING THAT WANT
CRIMINALS WALKING FREE ON THE
STREET WE WANT PEOPLE SENTENCED
FOR THE CRIMES THAT THEY COMMIT.
WERE JUST SEEM TO NOT THROW
PEOPLE'S LIVES AWAY BY OUR KICK
SENTENCING.
SHOP MECHANISM THAT WAS IN.
AN ACTIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN ON THIS
WHOLE TOUGH ON CRIME MOVEMENT WE
HAD DOUBLE THE BASED TERM WASN'T
ACTING IN CALIFORNIA IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WE HAD IT
FOR TWENTY YEARS UNTIL WE DECIDE
TO BECOME TOUGH ON CRIME AND
COME OUT WITH THIS ARE KICK
[inaudible]
OUCH.
LARA METHOD OF A SENTENCING
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW SO IT WORKED
ALL THE WAY UP UNTIL THAT TIME
AND IT'S THIS WHOLE ENHANCEMENT
IT'S REACHED OUR RESULT OF THIS
WHOLE TOUGH ON CRIME MOVEMENT
YOU GO.
AND BASED ON OUR OPPOSITION
CRIME HAS NOT DECREASED SO
OBVIOUSLY ARE TOUGH ON CRIME
METHODS HAVE NOT WORKED SO ALL
WERE SEEN AS NOT DON'T THOUGH
SOMEONE'S LIFE AWAY.
BASED ON SOME ARCHAIC BAH
CALCULATIONTHAT WE CAME UP WITH
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND GIVE PEOPLE
A CHANCE AND AND AND IT WOULD
APPEAR JUST SENTENCE.
THANK YOU SO I TO WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK ABOUT THIS
BILL --
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THESE ARE NOT MATH PROBLEMS THEY
ARE PEOPLE.
WHO COME BEFORE JUDGES WHO ARE
REPRESENTED BY ATTORNEYS IN
COURT HOUSES WHO OFTENTIMES ARE
FACED [inaudible]
BY JURIES HOPEFULLY A BUNCH OF
THEIR PEERS.
AND SO WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
YOU KNOW THESE ARE NOT.
ELSE OUT EXAMPLES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
IT.
THEY ARE HUMAN BEINGS SOME OF
THEM ARE TRYING TO REHABILITATE
MAYBE SOME OF THEM ARE NOT BUT
THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT FOR US TO
DECIDE.
IT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GO
BEFORE A JUDGE WHEN YOU HAVE DUE
PROCESS AND WHEN BOTH SIDES ARE
PRESENTING EVIDENCE.
AND SO I MIGHT QUESTION ALWAYS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NUMBER OF
THESE BILLS THAT COME BEFORE US.
IS IF WE ARE JUST TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO LOCK PEOPLE UP FOR EVER
MORE IF WE ARE TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
UPHOLDING DUE PROCESS WHILE
PUTTING FORTH AN ALLOWING WAYS
TO PUT FORTH COMMONSENSE
EVIDENCE.
SO THAT FOLKS CAN BE TRIED.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
OR ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MR BRADFORD YOU MAY.
CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK --
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION HERE THIS
MORNING AND APPLE.
ARE THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT THOUGH OPEN
THE FLOOD GATES ALLOW CRIMINALS
TO RUN FREE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR INTENT HERE IS TO COME UP
WITH EIGHT SENSIBLE SYMBOLIZE
METHOD AND WHICH WE AW SENTENCE
INDIVIDUALS AS FONG.
MISTER LACKEY --
STATED -- WE
HAVE THE ULTIMATE AND DUE
RESPECT FOR LONG FONG THE LAW
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S NOT OUR INTENT AT ALL.
BUT AGAIN EVIDENCE IF PROVEN
THAT [inaudible]
MADE OF THE DEATH SENTENCE HAS
NOT DETERRED NOT ONE PERSON FROM
COMMITTING MURDER.
BUT WE HAVE A DEATH SENTENCE AND
MANY STATE BUT IT HAS NOT
DETERRED PEOPLE FROM.
COMMITTING MURDER TO SHAME HERE
HAVING THIS ARCHAIC.
MY WAY OF CALCULATING SENTENCE
IS NOT A SINGLE CROCK CRIMINALS
THINKING YOU KNOW LET ME
CALCULATE THIS BEFORE I GO DO
THIS ARMED ROBBERY AND IF I DO
THIS AND I DO THIS AND I DO IT
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THEY'RE NOT THINKING LIKE THAT.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH
TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT WE
CREATED IN THIS LEGISLATURE
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RAGO.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
THE MOTION AND SECOND AND I
WANNA.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
SUBJECT UP --
OBVIOUSLY THE THE OPPONENT.
AND YOU MISTER BRADFORD A VERY
VERY PASSIONATE --
ABOUT THIS AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
LADY JUSTICE YOU SEE THE SCALES --
SOME OF US BELIEVE.
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS IT'S
BEEN MORE INCARCERATION AND
PUNISHMENT.
DAN OF REHABILITATION AND DIDN'T
PROVIDING AND SOMEHOW.
WE TRY TO REACH THAT BALANCED
THE DEEPEST BILL CADA GETS US TO
A LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO BALLOTS.
HOPEFULLY ALSO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE.
THAT.
PROBABLY SHOULD NEVER COME OUT
BE BACK ON THE STREETS AGAIN AND
I I BELIEVE YOU'RE SENSITIVE TO
THAT DISCERN NO.
NEED THE OPPONENTS ARE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT AND THIS
IS NOT [inaudible]
ABOUT -- I
DON'T GO WHAT USED TO TERMS OF
BUT IS NOT ABOUT PROVIDING
DISCOUNT. TO CRIMINALS AND SO AM
I I BELIEVE THAT IS NOT YOUR
INTENT WAS NOT TO BEGINNING
INTENT OR WHATEVER.
IT WAS TO PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR
WHICH ON INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
ABLE -- TO
REHABILITATE THEMSELVES INSTEAD
OF JUST SITTING AND IMPRISONED
FOR VERY LONG TERM.
AND OF THAT I KNOW YOU ARE ALSO.
VERY SENSITIVE TO WHAT THE LA
DEAYTON THE DJS ARE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT SALUTE THAT
[inaudible]
CULTURAL.
ON S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NOCAUTEADO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KAMLAGER-DOVE I
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURES ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS THANK YOU DECK
YOU [inaudible]
FOR THE TESTIMONY.
NOW WE HAVE MR WILK [inaudible]
S. B..
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR AND S. B.
FOURTEEN ALL NINE ITEMS
[inaudible]
AND SEVEN MY BELIEF AND
SEVENTEEN AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE ON CONSENT.
WHY DO WE LET SO MANY OUT?
NO MY NOT SO WE KNOW GOOD. TEN
TWENTY FOUR TWO TWENTY FOUR OKAY
FORTINO NINE AND THOSE WHO WAS A
PRESENTING ON YES OKAY GREAT.
FOR THE SAKE I'VE I MISPRONOUNCE
BUT DOES THE TEN TWENTY FOUR
WELL THANK YOU MISTER JUROR THE
BELL.
YOU KNOW THAT MEANS MISTER WELL
I DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
AND SO WITH THAT I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO SAY.
CLEARLY THE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THERE'S A LINK BETWEEN
EARLY ANIMAL ABUSE AND AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST PEOPLE AT A
LATER DATE. 90% A MASS SHOOTER
71% OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
OFFENDERS AND ALMOST 50% OF A
RAPIST I AM --
I WANNA THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON AND TAKING ALL THE
MANAGE RECOMMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
RELATING TO THE EDUCATION SO
WITH THAT ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A FIRST AND SO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WE DID [inaudible]
NICHOLAS SACKETT.
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PENNY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HOPE OUT THERE YOU
RETIREMENT I'M SORRY ON BEHALF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA WEAPON OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION --
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BELIEVED THAT THE AMENDMENTS
WILL ROUTE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
WILL REVIEW THOSE AND CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
BUT CHAIRS RECOMMEND I CALL THE
ROLL SB TEND TO BE FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
AYE AYE LACKEY AYE CARILLO
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
NOW.
THE SECOND BILL.
PORTANTINO NINE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN OH NINE
WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW TO
STREAMLINE THE PRODUCTION
CULTIVATION OF INDUSTRIAL HAPPEN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH OVER THIRTY OTHER NATIONS
IN NINETEEN STATES IN THE U. S.
GROWING INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
AND CALIFORNIA REPRESENT THE
LARGEST CONSUMER AND INDUSTRIAL
MARKET FOR HIM MATERIALS AND
PRODUCTS IN THE U. S..
CALIFORNIA IS IN A POSITION IS
WELL POSITIONED TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY --
ON TOP OF THE MANY MINOR USES OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP THE BENEFITS FOR
FARMERS ARE NOT ONLY FINANCIAL
BUT ALSO PRACTICAL.
CALIFORNIA'S NO STRANGER TO
DROUGHT LIKE CONDITIONS AND
INDUSTRIAL HEMP HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE IMMENSE
VALUE TO FARMERS AS IT REQUIRES
FAR LESS WATER THAN MOST CROPS.
REQUIRES LITTLE TO NO PESTICIDES
AND ACTUALLY READ GENERATES THE
SOIL.
INDUSTRIAL HEMP REQUIRES.
I DID ALL THAT SOMEONE SKIP ON
THAT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP IS A NATURAL FIT
FOR CALIFORNIANS ARID CLIMATE.
AT ONE POINT WE WERE THE
ACTUALLY THE LEADER WHEN WE
ENACTED SP FIVE SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR LENO WHICH ESTABLISH AN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP FARMING PROGRAM.
BUT AND FORCEFULLY PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR CONTAIN PROVISIONS
THAT LARGELY AND DID MUCH OF THE
PROGRESS BY LOPPING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP -- THE
AGRICULTURE COMMODITY WITH THE
INTOXICATING RELATIVE --
RELATIVE A CANNABIS ALSO SINCE
THEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAD
UPDATED THE THAT THE FARM ACT.
SOURCE BEFORE TO KNOW NINE WILL
ONCE AGAIN PUT CALIFORNIA AT THE
LEADING EDGE OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTION IN PROVIDE OUR
FARMERS A WATER SAVING
ALTERNATIVE TO CROPS LIKE CORN
AND ALFALFA.
YES BE FORTINO NINE IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT VOICE
VOTE JOINING ME THIS MORNING IS
I EIGHTY PER NAQI REPRESENTING
VOTE HIM.
AND CHRIS WILSON WITH --
HIGH ENERGETICS.
THANK YOU MAY BEGIN FIVE AND
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANY BERNACCHI
ON BEHALF OF VOTE HELP --
AS USUAL SOONER WILK HAS DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF OUTLINING --
THE NEED --
FOR LEGISLATION IN THIS AREA AND
THE BENEFITS OF THIS PRODUCT FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I LIKE INFLOWS SIMPLY THAT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
CLIENTS WITH PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AND IT SIMPLY ADDS
PILOT PROGRAM STATUS. TWO CDFA
THIS REGISTRATION PROGRAM SO
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
FARM BILL COMPLY.
BOTH OF THESE ITEMS ARE NEEDED --
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO
BEGIN A GROWING UP AND
PARTICIPATING IN WHAT IS OR WHAT
IS VASTLY GROWING OVER BUT IS
CURRENTLY A SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLAR.
INDUSTRY --
IMAGES BECAUSE I THINK YOU KNOW
THERE'S NINETEEN OTHER STATES AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED --
WHO HAVE?
GOTTEN A HEAD START ON
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE PRODUCTION CULTIVATION OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CALIFORNIA IS
THE AGRICULTURE.
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
AND WE SERIOUSLY AND AND BRING
POORLY NEED THIS BILL TO BE
PASSED -- TO
ENSURE THAT.
WE CAN CLOSE THAT GAP SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE
DRIVE UP THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
JEFF.
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CHRIS WILSON I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF OHIO ENERGETICS --
ó HIGH ENERGETIC THE HEMP
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY BASE OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT
CURRENTLY WE ARE FORCED OUT OF
STATE PLACE LIKE WORK IN
COLORADO TO SOURCE MANUFACTURE
HEMP PRODUCTS.
MANY CALIFORNIA COMPANIES LIKE
OURSELVES ARE UP BRING THE
BUSINESS IS MOVING OUT OF STATE
TO BE CLOSER TO HAVE CULTIVATION.
WITH CALIFORNIA BEING THE
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL STATE IN
THE U. S..
WE SHOULD NOT FAR BEHIND THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY IN EMERGING
HAVE BEEN HISTORY.
ARE CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE LEADING THE
WAY.
AS OUR HOPE.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO VERTICAL AS
OUR BUSINESS HERE IN OUR HOME
STATE.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PAST BEST
BEFORE TWO NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A WITNESS IS NOT POSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE COURT --
SENATOR WELL.
HOW COME YOU HAVE SO MANY GOOD
BUILDS UP THIS YEAR?
I HAVE GROWN IN OFFICE.
I MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WELL I JUST WANTED TO KNOW HOW
LARGE IS YOUR INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WELL FROM WHAT STANDPOINT THEM
FROM THE FOR HOW MANY THE FROM
CULTIVATIONS TEN POINT --
UNTIL THIS BILL PASSED --
THE STATE CALIFORNIA THE CDF
FACED BY THE PROGRAM WILL NOT BE
FORMAL COMPLAINTS THERE IS NO
INTERTROPICAL DIVISIONS GET
CALIFORNIA OKAY BUT THERE THERE
ARE MANY FACTORS LIKE GO AYE
ENERGETICS.
THAT IMPORT INDUSTRIAL HEMP FROM
OUT OF STATE. TO MANUFACTURE OR
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT OF STATE TO
MANUFACTURE WHERE THEY'RE CLOSER
TO THE ACTUAL CULTIVATION.
UP THEIR PRODUCTS IN THEIR
HEADQUARTERS ARE HERE AND ON THE
NUMBER OF HIM.
BUSINESSES AND STAY ON A CHRIS
IF IF YOU HAVE A NUMBER THERE
BUT IT'S IT'S PROBABLY INTO THE
FEW HUNDREDS --
AND I THINK IT COULD GROW
INCREASINGLY.
ACTUALLY THIS BILL CAME TO ME
FROM MY LOCAL LOCAL FARMER SO WE
JUST FINISHED IN THE ARAB VALLEY --
SIXTEEN YEARS OF LITIGATION ON
WATER RIGHTS IN THE BIG LOSERS
WAS THE AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR WATER CUT
BY 44% OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS --
THE PRIMARY CROP IS ALFALFA
WHICH REQUIRE SEVEN ACRE FEET OF
WATER.
PER ACRE INDUSTRIAL HEMP IS
UNDER.
TWO SO --
LITTLE NO PESTICIDES LESS WATER.
CROP ACTUALLY PAYS BETTER THAN
ALFALFA I'VE HAD MANUFACTURERS
ECONOMY SAID IF IF YOU GET THIS
BILL PASSED WE WILL COME TO YOUR
DISTRICT.
AND SET UP --
THE OUR MANUFACTURING COMPANIES%
BECAUSE THAT THEY HAVE WILL BE
THERE.
AND TO ALL THE NAYSAYERS OUT
THERE WHO WOULD THEN SAY WELL MY
GOD NO ONE ELSE IS GONNA BE
GROWING CORN OR ALFALFA THEY'RE
ONLY GOING TO BE GROWING HEMP
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THEM.
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GROW IT.
BUT THE YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT
THE MATTER IS IS IT'S NOT FOR US
THAT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE I MEAN
YOU KNOW.
WE YOU KNOW AS THE GOVERNOR SAYS
WE GET THE NEW NORMAL IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH
ARE AIR CLIMATE ANYWAY CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE WE HAVE TO BE
SMARTER LIVE GUIDE.
FARMERS WHO WANT TO REMAIN IN
THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR THE ONLY
WAY THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT IS IS CONVERT THEIR
THEIR CROPS THAT THAT FIT.
THE THE CONDITIONS THAT WE LIVE
IN AND HEMP IS ONE OF THE BEST
ROTATIONAL CROPS ACTUALLY HAD
HOPES TO REMEDIATE THE SOIL IT
BRINGS NITRATES NUTRIENTS BACK
IN THE SOIL SO --
AS A GOOD TAKES ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS AGO FULL CYCLE YOU
ACTUALLY CAN CYCLE IN WITH OTHER
CROPS IN IN GROW BETTER YIELDS
FROM THAT.
AND PROBABLY MUSCLES.
IT'LL IT'LL DEFTLY HELP WITH
PERFORMERS AND OTHER CROPS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE SELECTED A YOU KNOW I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY --
AS YOU OUTLINED.
ARE DISTRICTS OVERLAP AND DOES
THERE IS A GREAT TO FUTURE HERE
FOR THIS PRODUCT.
AND IT'S IT'S QUITE EMBARRASSING
THAT.
WE HAVE TO LEGISLATION TO ALLOW
TO MOVE FORWARD BUT VERY
THANKFUL THAT --
WERE -- HAVE
AND WHAT IT TAKES THE VISION IN
THE DISCUSSION. TO OF MATURE
EARLIER DRESS THIS ISSUE AND
ALLOW THIS PRODUCT. TO TO A MOVE
FORWARD ALLOW.
THE PUBLIC TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
THE SCRIPTWRITER ACT.
THANK YOU OF WE HAVE A LATE
BREAKING COMMENT.
IT IS JASON DRIVE OF THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
A IMPORTANT LOCAL CONTROL
PROVISIONS TO PROTECT NOT ONLY
HEMP CULTIVATION BUT ALSO
CANNABIS CULTIVATION TO ENSURE
THE CROSS POLLINATION ISSUES ON
EXIST.
HAVE SO WE'RE VERY THANKFUL OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS INSUPPORTABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO MISTER WILL CALL LONGER YOU
BEEN IN TO HELP.
NO NOT NOT SO MIGHT NOT TO MY
FARMERS PRIDE BUT FOR MY CLOTHES
NATION.
YOU KNOW FACT MATTER IS THAT HIM
IS IS AMERICA AS IT IS AS
AMERICAN AS HOT DOGS APPLE PIE
IN BASEBALL.
BETSY ROSS WHEN SHE'S SO HARD
THE FIRST AMERICAN FLAG WAS OUT
AT HIM.
WHEN THOMAS JEFFERSON DRAFTED
THE DECLARATION INDEPENDENCE IT
WAS ON HEMP PAPER VOTE SO HIT IS
AMERICA WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
BRING AMERICA BACK TO ITS FUTURE
WHICH IS HIP?
SO WITH THAT ASPIRIN AYE VOTE OR
I TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOSING THAT --
NICOLA ROLE.
BUT ON AS THE FORTUNATE NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER OPTIONS ARE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARDIO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
APPLE PIE I KAMLAGER-DOVE I
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSES GRADUALLY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR PELL.
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN MISTER CHAIRMAN I WAS
READING RECENTLY A BOOK ABOUT
GEORGE WASHINGTON.
I JUST WANT TO DISCLOSE THAT HE
GREW AND ALSO.
INTERESTING READING ABOUT HIM --
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
TODAY I'M PRESENTING --
THIS BILL --
EIGHT ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THIS
IS A BILL THE ELIM LIMITS THE
INVOLUNTARY.
PRE TRIAL COMPLETE CONFINEMENT
OF A PERSON SOLELY BASED ON HIS
OR HER MENTAL INCAPACITY TO
STAND TRIAL. FOR WHAT NO LONGER
THAN TWO YEARS.
CURRENTLY THREE YEARS WE'RE
GOING FROM THREE YEARS TO TWO
YEARS -- HIT
UPDATES ARCHAIC STANDARDS AND
DEFINITIONS WITHIN THE EXISTING
LAW.
NOW BY SHORTENING THE MAXIMUM
COMMITMENT PERIOD FOR FROM THREE
YEARS.
THE BILL INCREASES THE VEIL
ABILITY OF PLACEMENTS AND
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
HOSPITALS DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
FOR THE TREATMENT AND TO REMOVE
THE BALLOT.
INCOMPETENCE STAND TRIAL.
SPIDERMAN --
I'LL BE BRIEF AND IN.
THE IN ADDITION IT'S BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT --
THE BILL WILL SAVE MONEY.
SHORTER STAYS --
AND OUR STATE HOSPITALS DO KNOW
THAT WE ADDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE HOSPITAL IN
THE BUDGET.
JUST TO HANDLE INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL IT WAS BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO OVERCROWDED.
WITH THESE INCOMPETENT STAND
TRIALS THAT WE HAD TO ADD ALL
THIS MONEY SO THAT COUNTIES.
COULD FIND PLACES AND GREAT
PLACES FOR PEOPLE THAT WERE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
SO THIS IS A COST SAVER IF WE
APPROVE THIS BILL AND I'LL TURN
OVER TO MY WITNESSES MISTER TURN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAURA
AND MY NAME IS LAURA ARNOLD I'VE
BEEN A PUBLIC DEFENDER FROM MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS.
I CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS MENTAL HEALTH AND
CIVIL COMMITMENT COMMITTEE AND
ON BEHALF OF C. PDA AND PUBLIC
DEFENDER FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
BALLOT HIS STAFF FROM WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL AND I WOULD
URGE YOU TO VOTE I'ANSON ABOUT.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THE TREATMENT OF
MEDS ON ITS HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE PAST FORTY
FOUR YEARS IF YOU THINK ABOUT A
HALF CENTURY AGO THEY WERE USING
STE SHOCK TREATMENTS RIGHT.
BUT NOW MEDICATION TREATMENT HAS
REALLY INVOLVED AND WE'VE
REALIZED THAT WITH EFFECTIVE
MEDICATION TREATMENT PEOPLE CAN
BE RESTORED TO COMPETENCY MUCH
MORE QUICKLY.
THAN ANYBODY EVER WOULD HAVE
IMAGINED HAVE SIGNED YOUR LIMIT
WAS SELECTED --
COMPETENCY COMMITMENTS ARE
DESIGNED TO BE SHORT TERM
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY MEANT TO BE ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING SCHEME.
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO TAYLOR ACUTE
MENTAL ILLNESS WHICH IMPAIR A
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT TO SUCH A
DEGREE THAT HE CAN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON CAN ENTER A PLEA
CAN'T VIOLENT.
AGO I'M WITH THE MOTION HE CAN'T
GO TO TRIAL.
ON THOSE WHO ARE NOT RENDER
COMPETENT WITHIN THE MOST PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCOMPETENT ARE RESTORED
CONSTANCY WITHIN SIX MONTHS.
THOSE WHO ARE RESTORED WITHIN A
YEAR LIKELY NEVER WILL BE.
AS THIS GROUP KNOWS THERE'S A
LIMITED NUMBER OF TREATMENT BEDS
AVAILABLE AND THE MOST EXPENSIVE
ONES IN THE STATE ARE IN THE
STATE HOSPITAL THERE IN HIGH
DEMAND.
RIGHT NOW THE WEIGHT OF THE WAIT
LIST FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING
TO WHO ARE SITTING IN JAIL
WAITING TO GET INTO STATE
HOSPITALS AS MORE THAN A
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IT'S TAKING UP TO SIX MONTHS IN
LOS ANGELES FOR PEOPLE TO GET
PLACED IN A TREATMENT FACILITY.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW JAIL IS THE
WORST POSSIBLE ENVIRONMENT FOR A
PERSON SUFFERING FROM SEVERE AND
ACUTE MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND BY SHORTENING THE MAXIM
COMMITMENT AS THE ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WILL INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF PLACEMENTS IN
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES HOSPITALS
AND DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
WILL ACCELERATE THE PLACEMENT
AND TREATMENT OF INCOMPETENT
DEFENDANTS AND WILL SAVE THE
TAXPAYERS MONEY.
IN LINE WITH IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL SPEEDY TRIAL
RIGHTS OF DEFENDANTS AND VICTIMS
TREATMENT WILL BEGIN SOONER
COMPETENCY RESTORATION WILL
OCCUR MORE QUICKLY AND CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS CAN BE REINSTATED IN
CASES CAN BE ADJUDICATED. FOR
THOSE REASONS I URGE YOUR VOTE
FOR AYE VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THING BANG
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHARON RILEY ON BEHALF
OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AND THINKS THE SENATOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR WORKING.
WITH THE COUNCIL ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE COMMITTEE WELL
KNOWS AND AND WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL OR
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
CURRENTLY THE SYSTEM IS
OVERBURDENED AND THERE SIMPLY
ARE NOT ENOUGH BEDS. TO BE
AVAILABLE TO TREAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WE BELIEVE THE
COUNCIL BELIEVES THAT S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WILL HELP
RELIEVE PRESSURE ON THE SYSTEM.
BY OUR REDUCING WORK BURDENS
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE OCCUR
DURING THE THIRD YEAR OF
RESTORATION --%
CALLED FOUR IN CURRENT LAW THIS
IN TURNS FREES UP RESOURCES
ATTENDED A TO ATTEND TO THE
NEEDS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING.
FADS AND FREEZE UP SUPPORT --
TO DEAL WITH THE THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER HAPPY TO PROVIDE
SPECIFICS ABOUT EXACTLY WHY WE
THINK IT'LL REALLY PRESSURE ON
THE COURTS OF THE COMMITTEE --
IS INTERESTED AND THEN FINALLY
AS THOUGH LARA ARNOLD JUST
STATED THE COUNCIL AGREES THAT
S. B. ELEVEN SIX EIGHTY SEVEN IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT.
VIEW VIEWS OF MENTAL HEALTH
NEUROSCIENCE PROFESSIONAL.
IT'S THAT IT IS LIKE UNLIKELY
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN
FOUND AYE AS T. WILL RE RESTORED
COMPETENCY AFTER  PERIOD.
OF TWO YEARS.
THAT'S MAKING THE COURT
PROCEEDINGS IN THE THIRD YEAR
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
SUPPORT THE GOAL.
RESTORATION TO COMPETENCY FOR
THESE REASONS WE THE COUNCIL
WOULD URGE YOUR I'VE YOU TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THINK YOU THANK YOU OR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I YOU MAY CLOSE ARE MISSED
CHAIRMAN --
THE MOTIVATION FOR THIS BILL
FROM MY STANDPOINT CAME --
ONE I VISITED A TRUSTED HERO
HOSPITAL AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY I OF AS YOU KNOW I'VE
VISITED LE TAKE UP.
TO I KNOW I'M UP TO TWENTY FOUR
PRESENTS AND STATE HOSPITALS I
VISITED I'M GOING.
TO I INVITE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO THE TORE WERE DOING ON
THURSDAY --
AT THE BACK OF BILL MEDICAL --
FACILITY --
WE WE WE TALK TO THE ENTRY
PEOPLE WHERE THE BUS GOES INTO A
TRUST COULD RURAL.
AND I TALKED TO THE THE PEOPLE
THAT PROCESS PEOPLE AS THEY GOT
OFF THE BUS FROM THE COUNTY --
JAILS GOING INTO THE STATE
HOSPITAL THAT THESE ARE PEOPLE
OVERCONFIDENCE STAND TRIAL THAT.
WERE DELIVERED TO THE A TRUSTED
HERO AND I SAID WHAT KIND OF
FOLDERS YOU HAVE FROM.
PEOPLE --
MEDICAL FOLDERS AND SO FORTH.
PIECES JIM.
WE HAVE HARDLY ANY INFORMATION
ABOUT THESE PEOPLE.
THEY COME AND WE HAVE UNKNOWNS
WERE WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHO
THEY ARE.
THIS IT THIS WHOLE SYSTEM
DOESN'T WORK RIGHT.
SO I THINK THIS IS JUST THE
FIRST STAGE.
OF TRYING TO FIX A SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T WORK RIGHT.
AND THIS THIS THIS BILL GOES A
LITTLE BIT TOWARDS THAT
DIRECTION I SHOULD I VOTE.
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE.
THIS ISSUE OF OF HOW WE
ADJUDICATE PEOPLE THAT WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE --
JUSTICE FOR THESE PEOPLE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND
CULTURAL.
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARDIO.
CARILLO I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES GRADUATION
THANK YOU MISS
.
SIR WAY FOR MR PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
AND HUESO [inaudible]
AND SO.
AND SKINNER HAD DECIDED YET BUT
I KNOW SHE'S IN PUBLIC SAFETY
UPSTAIRS
HI GOOD MORNING SENATOR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN I
KNOW YOU.
YOU'RE BUSY [inaudible]
NO MORE. 80% S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH THE TAX
RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
TRACE THE TRACE TASK FORCES
STATEWIDE MULTI AGENCY EFFORT
THAT FOCUSES ON INVESTIGATING
PROSECUTING INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY MIGHT
ECONOMY.
THE TASK FORCE WHICH ORIGINATED
AS A PILOT PROGRAM ONLY CONSISTS
OF TWO TEAMS WITH THE
HEADQUARTERS IN SACRAMENTO.
RESPONSIBLE FOR INDEX
INVESTIGATIONS FROM BAKERSFIELD
TO THE OREGON BORDER.
AND LOS ANGELES RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SP TWELVE SEVENTY TWO AND THREE
ADDITIONAL HEADQUARTERS IN SAN
DIEGO THE BAY AREA AND FRESNO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS MARIO DIP
DAY BERNARDO ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARIO
DIBERNARDO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY OF THE SARAH.
WHO'S A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO A BILL THAT
WOULD PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH AND
STRENGTHEN THE TRACE TASK FORCE.
TO HELP COMBAT THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TAKES
ITS HEAVIEST TOLL ON HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
STRIPES.
MANY WORKERS GO WITHOUT BASIC
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS.
LAW BITING BUSINESSES ARE PUT AT
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE
THREATENED [inaudible]
MOREOVER.
TAX REVENUES ARE LOSS THAT COULD
OTHERWISE GO TO FUND LAW
ENFORCEMENT [inaudible]
EDUCATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CALIFORNIANS THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES.%
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN STATE
AGENCIES JOIN FORCES TO ADDRESS
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
ESTABLISHING THE TAX RECOVERY IN
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE
OR TRACE.
COR PARTNERS ALONG WITH DOJ OR
THE STATE'S MAIN.
TAXING AGENCIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
TOGETHER WE LEVERAGE OUR
EXPERTISE POOL OUR INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES WE DO THIS TO COMBAT
EGREGIOUS FELONY LEVEL CRIMES
INDIA IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
ARE USING TAX EVASION AS THE
MEASURE --
TO PROSECUTE.
THESE BAD ACTORS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
A BUSINESSES THAT ARE ENGAGING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SELLING
COUNTERFEIT GOODS SUCH AS A
LEGAL PHARMACEUTICALS COSMETIC
PRODUCTS.
TOBACCO THAT ARE UNREGULATED AND
OFTEN CAUGHT CONTAIN --
HAZARDOUS INGREDIENTS --
THE TRACE TASK FORCE STARTED
WITH THE SACRAMENTO TEAM AND
BRANCHED OUT TO LOS ANGELES
USING EXISTING RESOURCES.
AND A SHORT FEW YEARS OUR TEAMS
IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED TEN
MILLION ON REPORTED GROSS
RECEIPTS AND FORTY SIX MILLION
AND ASSOCIATED TAX LOSS TO THE
STATE.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF OR WE
HAVE COLLECTED OVER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN LOST TAX
REVENUE.
BUT WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
APPARENTLY ESTABLISHED THE TRACE
TASK FORCE WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THE BILL WOULD GIVE THE TASK
FORCE THE SUPPORT IT NEEDS TO
INVESTIGATE THESE CRIMES AND
RECOVER THE TAX REVENUES WE NEED
TO KEEP OUR STATE STRONG.
WE WOULD STRENGTHENED THE TEAMS
WE ALREADY HAVE IN SACRAMENTO IN
LA.
AND THEN BRANCH OUT TO THE OTHER
MAJOR METROPOLITAN AREAS IN THE
STATE THE BAY AREA FRESNO AND
SAN DIEGO.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE TREES TASK
FORCE TO MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY FIGHT UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY CRIMES THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE.
WOULD GO A LONG WAY IN HELPING
OUR STATE FUND VITAL PROGRAMS
AND PROTECT THE HEART.
OF THE RIGHTS OF HARDWORKING
CALIFORNIANS.
EMPLOYEES AND BUSINESSES WHO
PLAY BY THE RULES.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
SENATE FLOOR.
AND LIKE TO STAKE CENTER
GALGIANI AND CENTER ATKINS FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL AND THE BROAD
RANGE OF CO AUTHORS ARE BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND AND REPUBLICANS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL LOOKS
FORWARD [inaudible]
TO OF EFFORT ON THIS ISSUE --
WHICH IS CRITICAL TO OUR
IN THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
MARIA GARCIA GREENBERG TRAURIG
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE VERY GRATEFUL
AND SUPPORTIVE OF THIS EFFORT TO
COMBAT UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID IS
REALLY HURTING THAT LAW ABIDING
BUSINESSES THANK YOU ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT TIFFANY MAP IS ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HARDER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEIN NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I'M STILL NEW.
OUR HIGH SENATOR I JUST HAD A
QUESTION RECOVERED FONZIE
MENTIONED IN AN EFFORT --
TO RECOVER FUNDS ARE LOW WHERE
WOULD THOSE GOT WOULD THEY GO
BAY BACK INTO THE GENERAL FUND
OR THEY DISTRIBUTED.
THEY WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
AGENCIES THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
GONE TO ORIGINALLY [inaudible]
WHEN AND YEAH BUT WHAT THE FIRST
THAT IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE VICTIMS INVOLVED IN THE
CRIME THAT IT THAT ARE NOT STATE
AGENCIES THEY'D GET PRIORITY IN
TERMS OF RESTITUTION?
BUT THEN IT WOULD GO TO THE THE
VICTIM AGENCY WHICH WOULD OFTEN
GO TO THE GENERAL FUND OR IF
WE'RE DEALING LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
COUNTERFEIT TOBACCO PRODUCTS
THERE ARE THERE STATES STATUE
STATE LAW THAT DICTATES.
HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE WHERE THEY
SHOULD GO ON THE BILL INCLUDES A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT ANNUALLY
WHICH WOULD --
PROVIDE THE TRANSPARENCY TO SHOW
LEGISLATURE WHERE THE FUNDS
COLLECTED ARE ALL ABOUT THE
FINAL DISPOSITION OF THOSE FUNDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I ABOUT.
GREAT TO GET A MOTION.
SO CALLED WORLD.
ON S. BEAST TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER BY TO ANSWER AYE
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY GUY GAVRIEL CAVIAR I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES ADULATION
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
HUESO AND SKINNER.
AUG CUE MISTER PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
MEMBERS YOU HAD BEST BE ELEVEN
HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHT I DO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
IMMERSED TODAY I'M PRESENTING S.
B..
ELEVEN HUNDRED WHICH PROBE
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF FIREARMS BY
LICENSED DEALER TO ANY PERSON
BELOW THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE WELL
HANDGUNS ARE USED IN THE
MAJORITY OF GUN DEATHS.
LONG GUNS HAVE BEEN USED TO
PERPETUATE MANY OF THE LARGEST
MASS SHOOTINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THE TRAGIC EVENTS THAT
TOOK PLACE IN SAN BERNARDINO.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME. TO SOME OF
THE MOST STRINGENT GUN LAWS IN
THE COUNTRY ONE EXAMPLE OF THIS
IS REQUIRING INDIVIDUAL THE B.
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE IN ORDER
TO PURCHASE A HANDGUN.
SINCE CALIFORNIA STRIX GUN LAWS
HAVE TAKEN AFFECTION DATA SHOWS
THAT THERE'S BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
REDUCTION IN THE INCIDENCE OF
GUN TRAFFICKING. ONE NOT
BURDENING LEGITIMATE GUN OWNERS
ARE PERSONS WHO WISH TO ACQUIRE
GUNS.
IN ORDER TO BE YOU UNIFORMLY
CONSISTENT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
APPLY THE TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
AGE LIMIT. TO LONG GUNS.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
CALIFORNIANS HAVE TYPICALLY
PURCHASE MORE LONG GUNS THAN
HANDGUNS --
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
LONG GUNS WERE PURCHASED BY
PERSONS AGED.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY IN THE FIRST
QUARTER OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ALONE OF THE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
GUNS USED IN CRIMES THAT WERE
ENTERED INTO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AUTOMATED
FIREARM SYSTEM DATABASE. ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED WERE LONG
GUNS.
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT CERTAIN
GROUPS OF PEOPLE SUCH AS
LICENSED HUNTERS MILITARY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PREVENTING THE FLOW OF GUNS IS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
FIREARM AS A HANDGUN.
OR LONG GONE OR PURCHASE NEW
FROM A DEALER OR THROUGH A
PRIVATE PARTY TRANSACTION --
I HAVE AMANDA WILCOX FROM THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN --
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE --
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN GENERALLY
BELIEVES THAT HANDGUNS AND LONG
GUNS SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME LAWS --
BACK YEARS AGO.
I'VE THAT LONG GUNS WERE
PRIMARILY OF RIFLES ARE NOT THE
GRANDFATHER SHOTGUN LOCKED IN
THE CLOSET --
AND THEY WEREN'T TREATED THE
SAME BUT NOW THEM SO CALLED
MODERN PACE SPORTING RIFLE.
IS A HIGH POWERED CAN BE A HIGH
POWERED SEMI AUTOMATIC WITH
EXCHANGEABLE MAGAZINE ODD THAT
IS OR CAN BE MORE LETHAL MORE
THREATENING --
THAN A HANDGUN SO THERE'S NO WE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME LAWS THIS
BILL VOTE DOES NOT ACTUALLY ARE
SUBJECT LONG GUNS AND HANDGUNS
TO THE SAME LAW IT JUST
PROHIBITS THE PURCHASE OF A LONG
GONE.
BY SOMEONE AGE TWENTY ONE IT
DOES NOT PROHIBIT POSSESSION AND
AS YOU HEARD ON THE PROVIDES A
NUMBER OF EXCEPTIONS.
I'D ALLOWS FOR INTRA FAMILIAL
SALE OR TRANSFER OF A FIREARM SO
THAT THROUGH DICK TRADITION OF A
FATHER GIVING HIS SON HIS
HUNTING GUN CAN CONTINUE --
AT THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION JUST LAST WEEK I
ISSUED A STATEMENT ARE REGARDING
FIREARM --
GUM BINDS PREVENTION POLICIES
THAT THEY'RE NOW SUPPORTING AND
AMONG THOSE POLICIES THEY ARE
NOW SUPPORTING BANNING
POSSESSION AND USE OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION BY UNSUPERVISED
YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE AND SUPPORT BANNING THE
SALES OF FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION.
FROM LICENSE AN UNLICENSED
DEALERS TO THOSE UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE EXCLUDING CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF INDIVIDUALS SUCH
AS MILITARY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND I BELIEVE OF THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION --
IS ADOPTING THOSE POLICIES
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE AS TO WHY.
THAT --
MATURITY IMPULSIVE AND RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR AND RESPONSIBILITY VARY
GREATLY AMONG EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLDS --
FOR THAT THAT THEYARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LINKED TO
CRIME AND FIREARM HOMICIDES SO
IT MAKES COULD IT'S COMMON SENSE
AND IT CERTAINLY GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY --
TO RAISE THE MINIMUM AGE FOR
PURCHASE.
FOR OF A LONG GONE FROM A
FIREARM DEALER TO EACH.
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LADY BORTON REPRESENTING
AMERICAN CAN BE PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK.
MOVE THE BELL.
HERE NO OTHER QUESTION --
IT.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR ME
[inaudible]
AFTER.
HOUSE SPEAKER LOUDER NEXT TO HER
[inaudible] THIRTY DAYS.
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CREEK TO LOSE ABOUT HALF OF THE
FIREARMS POLICY COALITION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FEDERAL FIREARMS LICENSEES.
I JUST FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
WE'RE TALK WE'RE TALKING HERE IS
A CONSTITUTIONALLY ENUMERATED
RIGHT THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
ADULT YOU'RE CONSIDERED AN ADULT.
OF RESPOND YOU ARE LEGALLY
RESPONSIBLE BOTH CRIMINALLY AND
CIVILLY FOR THE DECISIONS THAT
YOU MAKE FOR THE CONTRACT THAT
YOU THAT YOU ENTER INTO --
WE YOU ARE ALLOWED TO VOTE YOU
CAN BE SENT HALFWAY ACROSS THE
WORLD HANDED A FIREARM IN ORDER
TO DEFEND YOUR COUNTRY AND WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS.
YOU DO NOT HAVE THAT SAME EXACT
RIGHT TO YOUR OWN HOME --
AYE I WOULD HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH --
WITH ONE POINT THOUGH.
WE BELIEVE THAT YES FIREARMS
LONG GUNS AND HANDGUNS DO NEED
TO BE TREATED THE SAME AND THAT
YOU SHOULD HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO OWN THEM.
EVEN AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN WE
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
TO BE TO BE ADULTS TO BE
CITIZENS AND HAVE FULL ACCESS TO
THE RIGHTS THEREOF.
OR WE'RE GOING TO SAY THAT AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE YOU ARE NOT AN
ADULT AND THEREFORE YOU DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THE RIGHTS.
THEIR OF EITHER WAY WE NEED TO
MAKE A DECISION I THINK THAT
YOU'RE A GROWN UP AN ADULT IN
THE CITIZEN AND YOU HAVE RIGHTS.
OR YOU DO NOT FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SEPARATE IS REPRESENTING
GOMEZ CALIFORNIA TWO POINTS
NUMBER ONE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RECOGNIZES ANYBODY
OVER THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN AS A
MEMBER OF THE MILITIA.
TONY CONSCRIPTION TONY
REGISTRATION OR ANYTHING THEY
ARE RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MEMBER THE
MILITIA AND THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY DENIES.
THE SECOND AMENDMENTRIGHTS OF
MEMBERS OF THE MILITIA.
WHICH WAS A PURPOSE THAT.
YOU NEED THE IN THERE WITH THAT
THE THE SECOND AMENDMENT WANTED
TO PROTECT HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
THE CITIZENRY TO COME UP WITH
THEIR OWN GUNS THAT THEY OWN AND
BROUGHT IN ORDER TO DEFEND THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY PREVENTS
IT PEOPLE ARE GONNA SAY WELL YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE DONE IT WITH
HANDGUNS WELL IT'S GOT AWAY WITH
HANDGUNS BECAUSE WE HAVE CHOSEN
NOT TO SUE.
ON THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THAT
THING NOW THAT IT'S A A CLEAR.
ACROSS THE COURT --
BLANKET -- A
SITUATION THERE WILL BE A
LAWSUIT JUST LIKE THERE WAS A A
LAWSUIT FILED IN IN IN FLORIDA
AND SECONDLY.
JUST LOGIC AND AND AND EQUAL
THINKING.
YOU THE STATEMENT MATURITY
IMPULSIVE AND RECKLESS BEHAVING
RESPONSIBLY VARY GREATLY AMONG
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY YEAR OLDS.
I MEAN IF IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THEN THEN YOU WOULD BE
CONSIDERING IF YOU REALLY WANT
TO SAVE LIVES WITH THE SHOULD BE
ALLOWING ANYBODY FROM. EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY TO DRIVE SINCE MORE
KID FROM THE MIS USE OR RECKLESS
USE OF OF CARS IN THE DO WITH
FIREARMS IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
YOU YOU YOU MIGHT HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT COLLEAGUES.
THEY MIGHT BE RECKLESSLY USING
THAT.
RIGHT THAT WE HAVE GIVEN THEM
THROUGH LEGISLATION TO VOTE.
WHICH IS A HUGE RESPONSIBILITY
SO YOU KNOW TO SAY ALL YOU'RE
YOU'RE TOO DUMB TOO STUPID TOO
IMMATURE TO TO OWN A GUN AND
DEFEND YOURSELF NOW MIND YOU
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY.
WHO HAVE SERVED OUR SERVICE AND
HAVE SEPARATED FROM THE MILITARY
BEFORE THEY'RE?
TWENTY ONE AND WITH THIS BILL
SAYS THAT IF YOU COME BACK TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU GET MARRIED AND YOU HAVE A
FAMILY AND YOUR HONOR TWENTY ONE
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE BEEN OFF
THE FOREIGN WARS AND DONE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS.
YOU CAN'T COME BACK YOU KNOW
LONGER MEMBER OF THE MILITARY.
YOU CAN COME BACK AND DEFEND
YOURSELF FOR YOUR FAMILY AND
YOUR HOME BECAUSE YOU'RE UNDER.
TWENTY ONE DOESN'T MAKE A WHOLE
LOT OF SENSE SO. FOR THESE
REASONS AND AND AND OTHERS --
OF WHERE WE'RE JOINED BY SOME OF
OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES THE IN IN
OPPOSITION.
A WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND RE
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE A LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL.
LOOKING TO RESTRICT THE RIGHTS
OF LAW ABIDING CITIZENS RATHER
THAN GOING AFTER THE CRIMINAL
MISUSE OF FIREARM SITS.
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN REPEAT REPEAT RESTRICTING
THE RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING FOR
THOSE REASONS REPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN ROY GRAVERT OF THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUES WHO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHURCHILL MCMAHON LE LAST
WEEKEND I SPENT THE OF THE WEEK
YOU WITH THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
KIDS.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SHOTGUNS ALL OVER THE PLACE
DAHLE HAVE A GOOD TIME.
ALL VERY SAFE.
AND ON THEIR BEHALF IN MY BEHALF
I HAS FOR YOU KNOW VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION SPARK CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS WAS
COALITION OUTDOOR SPORTS WITH
COALITION AND SIX CALIFORNIAS
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY OWN OPPOSITION.
MIGHT ALSO POINT OUT THAT WOMEN
ARE THE THE ONES THAT ARE REALLY
PURCHASING FIREARMS NOW AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUNG WOMEN
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES HE MIGHT BE
SINGLE MOTHERS.
WHO ARE UNDER TWENTY ONE WHO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU ARE
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE I BELIEVE
TWENTY FIVE TO RENT A CAR --
RIGHT.
SO THAT THERE ARE REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS ON MULTIPLE THINGS --
WE KNOW THAT --
THE TWO DEADLY SCHOOL SHOOTING
SANDY HOOK AND STONEMAN DOUGLAS
WERE PERPETRATED.
BY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY OR L.
TWENTY YEAR OLDS WITH LONG GUNS
WE KNOW.
THAT THE SURVIVORS IN FLORIDA
HAVE PASSIONATELY MADE THE CASE.
THAT THE CASUAL GUN PURCHASE BY
A TEENAGER SHOULD BE PROHIBITED
AND WE SHOULD RAISE THE AGE.
TO TWENTY ONE I THINK WE SHOULD
RESPOND TO THOSE PLEASE I THINK
IF WASHINGTON WON'T.
LEAD CALIFORNIA WILL --
INDIVIDUALS. 184% OF THE
POPULATION BUT COMMIT 17% OF GUN
HOMICIDES.
YOUNG ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WHICH WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING AS WELL --
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TWENTY
THREE POINT 4% OF THOSE ARRESTED
FOR MURDER.
AYE NON NEGLIGENT MANSLAUGHTER
IN THE U. S. WERE UNDER --
TWENTY ONE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS --
THIS IS A REASONABLE APPROACH
WITH I THINK APPROPRIATE
EXEMPTIONS THAT MAKE SENSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU --
IT IT JUST DISS WHAT ELSE THINKS
QUORUM.
KNOWN I WAS YOUNG AND I WAS
EIGHTEEN I I THOUGHT I HAD A
RIGHT TO SMOKE AND DRINK ALCOHOL
OR SMOKE WEED TOO BUT I WAS
PROHIBITED FROM --
IN A MORE SERIOUS NOTE --
THAT THAT THE AMOUNT OF
ACCIDENTS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
INVOLVED IN --
A LOT OF BECAUSE OF DRINKING AND
UNDER THE INFLUENCE AND SO ON IT
IS.
IT IS FOR THAT REASON THAT WHY
WE DO RESTRICT.
YOUNG PEOPLE AT CERTAIN AGES
FROM DOING THINGS BECAUSE
THEY'RE TO JUST NOT READY YET.
AND I DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
EXAMPLE OF RAIN CAR SO OF THE
YES IT DOES SEEM TO BE.
AND CONSISTENT.
ROOM BUT IS INCONSISTENT FOR A
REASON.
CONSIDER FOR REASON FOR OF TO
WHAT THAT --
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
YOU HAVE A REALLY.
THE GOOD MOTION.
IF IT.
I SB ELEVEN HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER I JOBS
ARE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO.
CALLIOPE AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER WEINER.
YOU HAVE S. B. TWO TO ONE AND S.
B. [inaudible]
NINE NINE ZERO BUILT.
SO RIGHT ALONG DISCUSS
[inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
WHICH WHICH ONE OF YOUR
OKAY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY OKAY
BEHIND YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THANK YOU FOR ON HEARING THIS
ITEM TODAY COLLEAGUES --
SENATE BILL --
TWO TWENTY ONE WILL BAN ON GUN
SHOWS AT THE COW PALACE WHICH IS
THE STATE FAIRGROUNDS.
THAT SITS ON THE BORDER BETWEEN
THAT [inaudible]
ESCO -- CAL
PALACE HOSTS ARE FIVE MULTI DAY
GUN SHOWS --
EVERY YEAR --
THIS BILL WILL TAKE EFFECT ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SO
THAT WE ARE NOT CAUSING THE CAL
PALACE TO BREACH.
ITS CURRENT CONTRACT WHICH RUNS
THROUGH LATE --
TWENTY NINETEEN BECAUSE IT BCAL
PALACE IS A STATE OWNED
FAIRGROUND.
ONLY THE STATE CAN RESTRICT
GONSALVES AT THIS SITE.
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE ZERO
AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
I THIS IS NOT CONTROVERSIAL IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I THE GOVERNING BODIES ARE
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS AND SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY AND CEMETERY
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE DALY CITY
CITY COUNCIL --
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR DECADES
TO GET RID OF THESE GUN SHOWS --
FOR THIS BILL WE HAVE UNANIMOUS
RESOLUTIONS UNANIMOUS VOTES.
THE SEVERED CISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS UNANIMOUS VOTE THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
UNANIMOUS VOTE ON DALY CITY
COUNCIL.
AS WELL AS UNANIMOUS VOTES ARE
OUT OF THE SCHOOL BOARDS SAN
FRANCISCO --
AND JEFFERSON AND UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT --
SO AGAIN THIS IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL LOCALLY YET OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE NO
ABILITY TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
STEPPING IN.
WE HAVE A UNANIMOUS --
SUPPORT CO SPONSORSHIP.
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION FROM BOTH
SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY AND SAN
MATEO.
COUNTY I WANT TO THANK MY CO
AUTHORS ARE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE IMPRINT NOW PROTESTING --
VIEWS -- GUN
SHOWS AND SAYING THEY WANT THEM
TO NOT BE THERE ANYMORE --
AND WE KNOW THAT NATIONALLY ARE --
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOW TAKING OVER
A LOT OF THE LEADERSHIP --
AGAINST V. EPIDEMIC OF GUN
SHOOTINGS ON GUN MURDERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
OF THIS COUNTRY IS AWASH IN GUNS.
ARE WE HAVE --
TWO AGENDAS EPIDEMIC OF MASS
SHOOTINGS I AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
FRUSTRATING --
I WILL SAY THAT THIS GUN SHOW
CONTINUES TO EXIST RIGHT ON THE
BORDER OF SAN FRANCISCO --
AND DALY CITY OUR COMMUNITY
WANTS --
THESE GUN SHOWS NOT HAPPEN
ANYMORE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AYE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I'VE JUST LUMINOL LOW WHO ARE
WHO IS THE MAYOR OF DALY CITY --
AS WELL AS A MIRROR TO LOOK WHO
IS A STUDENT AT SKYLINE COLLEGE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND CEMETERY
COUNTY --
AND UNTIL RECENTLY WAS A
JEFFERSON UNION HIGH SCHOOL --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU NEW THE FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL.
WE WERE WHICH BEGIN FIRST.
THERE YOU GOOD GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED JONES SAWYER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUST WOMAN ON THE MAYOR OF DALY
CITY.
I'M HERE THIS MORNING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO ONE
WHICH BECAUSE THE BAN ON GUN
SHOWS AT THE COW PALACE IN DALY
CITY.
S. B. TWO TWO WHY WOULD PROHIBIT
THE SALE OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION WERE AND OUR
COMMUNITY AT THE STATE OWNED CHO
HAU PALACE.
WHICH IS AND ONE A DISTRICT
AGRICULTURE ASSOCIATION THE COW
PALACE AND OTHER STATE OWNED
FACILITIES HOST GUN SHOWS
SEVERAL YEARS AND MOST RECENTLY
IN APRIL AND AGAIN ON JUNE NINTH
OF THIS YEAR.
DESPITE THIS LONGSTANDING
HISTORY OF GUN SHOWS THAT THE
COP PALACE TIMES HAVE CHANGED
EXISTING LAWS THAT REGULATE THE
SALE AND TRANSFER OF FIRE ARMS
IN OUR STATE AND COUNTRY.
HAD PROVEN AN ADEQUATE AND
REDUCING THE INCIDENCE OF MASS
GUN VIOLENCE THAT WE HAVE ALL
WITNESSED.
TRAGICALLY THESE INCIDENTS HAVE
SERIOUSLY IMPACTED STUDENTS AND
YOUTH ACROSS THE NATION AND IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT --
SEVEN CHILDREN SLASH TEENS UNDER
NINETEEN ARE KILLED WITH GUNS ON
AN AVERAGE A DAY IN THIS NATION
AS A MAYOR DALY CITY I'M
ESPECIALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF MY
COMMUNITY.
AND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD RAISE
RECENT INCIDENTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
OCCURRING IN THE NATION I'M
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING THE
STUDENTS OF DALY CITY.
THE BASE OUR NEIGHBORHOOD OF
DALY CITY HOME TO THE COW PALACE
HAS.
A T. THROUGH AIDS EIGHTH GRADE
SCHOOL CHILD DEVELOPMENT CENTER
AND COMMUNITY CENTER WITHIN ITS
VICINITY ALL OF WHICH I'D LIKE
TO PROTECT FROM POTENTIAL GUN
VIOLENCE.
AS POLICY MAKERS THE CITY OF KAT
THE COUNCIL DALY CITY ALONG WITH
THE GOVERNING BODIES IN THE CITY
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO OUR
NEIGHBORING CITY THE COUNTY OF
SAN MATEO ALL BOYS ONGOING
CONCERN.
ABOUT THE GUN SHOWS IN COW
PALACE IRONICALLY BOTH DALY CITY
AND SAN FRANCISCO PROHIBIT GUN
SHOPS IN OUR RESPECTIVE.
JURISDICTIONS YET IT IS
FRUSTRATING THAT A LOOPHOLE
TODAY'S PROHIBITION EXISTS AT
THE COW PALACE.
THEREBY IMPACTING BOTH OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I JUNE ELEVENTH THE CITY COUNCIL
IN DALY CITY UNANIMOUSLY ENDORSE
SPT TO WONDER WHETHER PASSAGE
RESOLUTION OF NUMBER EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THE COUNCIL MY
RECOGNIZE TO ADOPTION OF THIS
RESOLUTION THAT THE SURGEON MASS
GUN VIOLENCE.
AND CONTINUING SALE OF GALS GUN
SALES AT THE STATE OWNED
FACILITY CALLS FOR ELECTED STATE
REPRESENTATIVES TO TAKE A STAND.
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE BY ACTING
SO.
CHOOSE THE NUMBER OF FIRE ARMS
ON THE STREETS ARE BEING SOLD AT
THE COW PALACE AND GUN SHOWS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ON BEHALF THE
RESIDENTS OF DALY CITY
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO LIVE IN
THE SHADOW OF COW PALACE.
AND THOSE SAFETY OF A PARAMOUNT
CONCERN I URGE AN AFFIRMATIVE
VOTE.
AND S. B..
TWO TO ONE A CERTIFIED COPY OF
OUR RESOLUTION HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED FOR INCLUSION IN THE
IN THIS COMMITTEE HEARING AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
WINNERS LEGISLATION SB.
TWO TO ONE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
DESK.
I AM SO AGAIN I WANT TO EXTEND
MY THANKS TO THE CHAIR IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR HEARING US
OUT TODAY --
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY PEERS --
THE GUN EPIDEMIC IN THE UNITED
STATES HAS ABSOLUTELY TAKEN ITS
TOLL ON THE STUDENTS IN MY AREA.
SCHOOL HEARING ABOUT.
THE LEADER SHOOTING THAT'S
HAPPENED IN THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
JUST A SENSE OF ABSOLUTE AND
PERVASIVE FEAR.
IT EXISTS EVERY SINGLE TIME WE
WALKED SEUSS'S ON TO CAMPUS
EVERY SINGLE TIME WE WALK INTO
OUR CLASSROOMS.
IT'S THE IDEA OF GUNS AND
KNOWING THAT GUNS ARE BEING
OPENLY SOLD IN THE AREA AND THAT --
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO GUNS ARE
BEING SOLD AT THE COW PALACE
THAT THERE'S AN ACTIVE PROMOTION
AND TOUTING OF THE IDEA THAT.
GUNS ARE JUST THIS RIGHT THAT
EVERYBODY HIGHS AND IF SOMEBODY
WANTS TO WALK ON THE CAMPUS WITH
A GUN THEY CAN EASILY GET IT.
RIGHT NEAR THE SCHOOL ITS
MINUTES AWAY FROM THREE
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS OTHER
COPPOLA'S WITH GUNS ARE SOLD
INTO SEX WITH THREE DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SERVING THOUSANDS OF KIDS AND
NONE OF THEM FEEL SAFE WALKING
ON THE CAMPUS --
RECENTLY IN THE PAST YEAR WE'VE
HAD AN INCREASE IN US SAFETY
DRILLS ON OUR SCHOOL.
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SIT THERE
IN THE CLASSROOM HUDDLED IN THE
CORNER WHILE THE TEACHERS
TURNING THE LIGHTS OFF AND
GRABBING A BAT FROM THE BACK OF
THE CLASSROOM STANDING IN FRONT
OF THE DOOR AND NOT IMAGINE. OH
MY GOD.
I COULD ABSOLUTELY BE THE NEXT.
SCHOOL SHOOTING THIS COULD
ABSOLUTELY BE THE NEXT NEWS
HEADLINE THAT MY SCHOOL IS THE
LEAD NEXT.
ONE TO HAVE STUDENTS DIE IN A
PLACE WHERE THE SUPPOSED TO FEEL
SAFE AND FEEL EDUCATED
[inaudible]
IT'S TERRIFYING TO CONSIDER AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE REALITY
WE LIVE IN AND KNOWING THAT
THESE GUN SHOWS ARE CONTINUING.
RIGHT MINUTES AWAY FROM WHERE
KIDS ARE WALKING A LITTLE
SIBLING SO SCHOOL OR EATING
THEIR LUNCH IN THE CAFETERIA IS
ATROCIOUS AND ASTOUNDING.
AND THE STUDENTS IN OUR AREA
HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN UP ABOUT IT
THERE'S BEEN PROTEST BY THE HIGH
SCHOOL IS IN OUR AREA SAYING
THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THESE
GUNS BEING SOLD IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR SCHOOLS
NEAR THEIR SIBLINGS.
NEAR THEIR STUDENTS AND HOW
THEIR LIVES BEING PUT
[inaudible]
IN DANGER. FOR FOR NOTHING
BASICALLY SO I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE STUDENTS WHO WE SAY WE
HIGHLY HIGHLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER PASSING THIS BILL SO
THAT.
WE KNOW THAT OUR LIVES ARE SAFE
IN YOUR HANDS AND IN THE HANDS
OF OUR TEACHERS AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BOB BAILEY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SPOILER IN
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
SAN FRANCISCO LONGSTANDING
POLICY ON THIS --
TO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
APPRECIATES OUR WE ARE NOT
LETTING GO OF THE ISSUE THANK
YOU OR DRIVER.
THANK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STACEY
DOLL AND BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT COUNTY OF SAN
MATEO IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA STUDENT ACTIVISTS IN
SUPPORT.
I'M ERICA CARDOZO FROM JEFFERSON
HIGH SCHOOL I'M ONE OF THE
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE RIGHT BY
BAYSHORE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ALONG
WITH HUNDREDS.
AND HUNDREDS OF CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES THAT ARE VERY
CLOSE TO WHERE THESE ON YOUR
NAME WEAPONS ARE BEING SOLD IN
SHOWN I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL CLEAN IS LAGGING I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF CHECHNYA HIGH
SCHOOL DISHING ON BEHALF OF MY
BOARD AND I STUDENTS WE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIE BROWN ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION HOW
WE REPRESENT.
ALL THE SEVENTY EIGHT
FAIRGROUNDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE COW
PALACE --
THIS IS A STATE OWNED FACILITY
AS A HAS BEEN DISCUSSED IT IS
ALSO OVERSEEN IN GOVERNED BY A
BOARD OF DIRECTORS THAT ARE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR. ONE
OF THEIR MAIN RESPONSIBILITY IS
THE UPKEEP AND MAINTENANCE OF
THIS FACILITY WHICH IS DONE BY
REVENUES FROM THE SHOWS.
AND THE RENTALS THAT TAKE PLACE
AT THE COW PALACE WHICH DOES
INCLUDE GUN SHOWS --
WE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN CENTER LENO
BROUGHT IT --
FOR VERY SIMILAR PURPOSES AT
THAT TIME THE STATE WAS ACTUALLY
I HAD INVESTING ABOUT THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR INTO THE
ENTIRE NETWORK AFFAIRS.
SINCE THAT TIME --
MOST OF THAT MONEY HAS GONE AWAY --
LEAVING THE DID ASIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH THAT
RESPONSIBILITY OF GENERATING THE
REVENUE NECESSARY TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN.
AND AT THE SAME TIME NOT ONLY
COVERING OPERATING EXPENSES --
BUTTON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
NEEDS MOST FAIRGROUND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO SERVICE
EMERGENCY CENTERS.
A DURING DISASTERS THE CAL
PALACE AS AN EXAMPLE EYES FACING
THE SITUATION WITH A ROOF THAT
SEVERELY NEEDS REPAIR TO THE
TUNE OF ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS INCLUDING OTHER
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT THEY
HAVE.
THE STATE COMING IN AND TELLING
THEM WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT DO
IN TERMS OF REVENUE JUST SIMPLY
TIES THE HANDS OF THAT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS EVEN MORE THAN THEY
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS IN OUR MIND NECESSARILY
ABOUT GUN SHOWS ARE NOT.
THIS IS ABOUT REVENUE FOR A
STATE OWNED FACILITY THAT
RECEIVES LITTLE TO NO ASSISTANCE
FROM THE STATE SO THAT IT CAN
EXIST TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT.
IT HAS UNDER STATUTE AND SO.
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THESE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS BUT IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD AND START TO DICTATE
WHAT CAN AND CANNOT HAPPEN ON A
STATE OWNED FACILITY.
THEN WE WOULD ASK THAT THEY AT
THE SAME TIME COME FORWARD WITH
THE NECESSARY FUNDING.
THAT REPLACES THOSE DOLLARS SO
THAT THESE BUILDINGS THESE
FACILITIES CAN CONTINUE TO EXIST
OTHERWISE YOU PUT THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION.
OF OF BEING.
BEEN CONSTRAINED ON WHAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY DO TO KEEP THESE
FACILITIES OPEN THEREFORE WERE
OPPOSED AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NOT
CAPULETS REPRESENTING CROSSROADS
OF THE WEST --
WE WORKED --
GOING BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WAS SENATOR CORBETT ON
LANDMARK LEGISLATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REGULATING
GUN SHOWS IT IT TODAY IS.
CONSIDERED REALLY THE PRIDE OF
THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF GUN SHOW
MANAGEMENT I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN INCIDENTS AT
GUN SHOWS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE COW PALACE FACILITY ON WITH
THE SHOW ON EXISTS BRINGS IN
NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY --
IN AND OUT YEAR SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS --
FOR THE SHOW THAT.
YOU KNOW ALL THE ADDED COSTS OF
CONCESSIONS AND OTHER THINGS I
MIGHT POINT NOW --
I THINK IT'S A MISNOMER TO
SUGGEST THAT YOU WALK INTO A GUN
SHOW WALK OUT WITH A GUN --
BAIT BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE MADE SURE OF WHEN WE PASSED
THE ORIGINAL STATUTE WAS THAT
YOU COMPLY WITH ALL THE LAWS OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE WAITING
PERIODS IN CALIFORNIA SO.
OF FIREARMS DO NOT GONNA.
TO OUT THE SHOW PER SE YOU MAY
START A WAITING PERIOD BUT YOU
CANNOT COMPLETE THE TRANSACTION
THERE SO ALL THE LAWS ARE
COMPLIED WITH.
THE SHOWS OPERATE ON THE WEEKEND
WHEN SCHOOLS ARE NOT IN SESSION
AND WE WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT
THIS IS REALLY A FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUE AS WELL THIS OF STATE
OWNED PROPERTIES.
WHERE LEGAL ACTIVITIES GO ON --
WENT CENTER LENO CARRIED THE
BILL I KNOW WE HAD A VERY --
INTERACTIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT GO
ON AT THE COW PALACE ON AND IT'S
VERY DIVERSE AND WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THAT BUT IF TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE INVOLVED
AND ALL LEGAL ACTIVITIES SHOULD
BE AUTHORIZED IF THEY'RE
COMPLYING.
WITH THE LAWS OF THE FACILITY.
WOULD ALSO SAY UP LASTLY THAT UC
DAVIS --
CONDUCTED A STUDY ON GUN SHOWS
IN CALIFORNIA --
KAREN WHEN A MUTE WHO IS
SPONSORED SECOND AMENDMENT PER
SE.
BUT FOUND THAT THE GUN SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ACTUALLY BY HIS
DEFINITION BORING BECAUSE THEY
THEY WERE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW AND THAT THE WERE NOT
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES GOING ON SO
WE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND THINK TIME IS BETTER SPENT
ON SOME OF THE SCHOOL SAFETY
MAJORS THAT ARE MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MAN ORGANIZATION.
A CRADLE LOSE ABOUT THE FIREARMS
POLICY COALITION --
IN OPPOSITION IF I IF I MIGHT
JUST HAVE JUST. ONE MORE WORK GO
OUT WHEN I THINK THAT WOULD NOTE
IS IS THAT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
NOTED BY BOTH THE AUTHOR AND BY
ONE OF THE PEOPLE TESTIFYING
THAT YOU OF LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
ARE BASICALLY SAYING.
WE'RE GOING TO DENY YOU THE
ABILITY TO EXERCISE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT YOU CAN OWN
A GUN YOU JUST CAN'T.
PURCHASE A GUN AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO LIMIT THE ONLY ABILITY
THE ONLY WAY IN WHICH SOMEONE
CAN OBTAIN WILL BE ABLE TO
FACILITATE OR EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO KEEP AND
BEAR ARMS.
WITHIN THAT WITHIN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA --
WE SEE THIS AS A MAJOR PROBLEM
THEREFORE WE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
OF REPRESENT GUNS CALIFORNIA
ENABLE ORGANIZATION.
AND A BIG PORTION I'M JUST
STATING OR REPRESENTING.
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
THIRTY NINE POINT EIGHT A
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE RESIDENTS
AND OWNERS OF THE CAL PALACE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SAM.
OR CHAIRMAN FOR THE RECORD DAN
REED WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN ROY GROUP THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS WHO
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO SAN MATEO
COUNTY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR TIM MCMAHON I WAS
AT THE COW PALACE TEN DAYS AGO
AND I COLLECTED ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY SIX SIGNED
LETTERS AGAINST THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK --
SO MY MY CONCERN AND THE REASON
WHY WON'T BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL.
IS THAT I JUST FEEL THAT THIS
ARM.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE ALL
THE LAWS ARE OBSERVED --
AND IF PEOPLE DON'T BUY A GUN
HERE I'M WORRIED THAT THEY WILL
BUY A GUN IN THE PLACE WHERE ALL
THOSE LAWS AREN'T OBSERVED.
I SUPPORTED DAD
DECRIMINALIZATION OF DRUGS OF
PROSTITUTION.
ARE AT CENTER AND THIS TO ME IS
YOU NOW WE OUGHT TO HAVE THINGS
IN THE OPEN.
WHERE THE CONTROL TO NOT ALLOW
THEM TO GO UNDERGROUND AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT BY?
UP PROHIBITING.
A SITUATION WHERE ALL THE LAWS
ARE OBSERVED WHERE EVERYTHING IS
TAKEN CARE OF THE THINGS GO
UNDERGROUND AND I JUST CAN'T
SUPPORT THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP IN NEW MAKE [inaudible]
GOOD.
OUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE MR
CHAIRMAN AND I DO WHAT IS NOTE
THAT --
BECAUSE THERE WAS A NUMBER
THROWN OUT BEFORE ABOUT --
REVENUE BY THE KELP PALACE HAS
TOLD US THAT THEIR ANNUAL
REVENUE FROM THE GUN SHOWS IS
SOMEWHERE.
IN THE 1-002-002-5000 DOLLAR
RANGE THAT'S OUT OF FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE
SO IT IS SOMETHING I'M NOT
DISMISSING THA NUMBER BUT IT IS
A TINY PERCENTAGE OF A CAL
PALACES -- I
AM I AM CONFIDENT THEY CAN MAKE
THAT OUT I WILL ALSO SAY THAT --
THE COW PALACE HAS OWNS A LOT OF
LANDS AND OTHER CITY OF DALY
CITY FOR YEARS HAS BEEN TRYING
TO WORK WITH THE CAL PALACE. ONE
SOME REDEVELOPMENT OF THAT LAND
THAT'S NOT REALLY BEING USED FOR
VERY MUCH --
RIGHT NOW --
TO TRY TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY THERE ARE MANY REVENUE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE KALPOE US --
AND I KNOW THAT --
ASSEMBLYMAN --
TING MY CO AUTHOR AND I ARE IN
CONVERSATION WITH THEM WE WANT
TO BE HELPFUL IN FACILITATING.
AYE THOSE CONVERSATIONS YOU KNOW
ARE IN THE AND THIS IS ABOUT --
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVING THE
ABILITY --
TO TO PROTECT THEMSELVES TO
PROTECT OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
THAT THEY CAN'T DO THAT HERE SO
WE NEED TO DO IT FOR THEM AND I
RESPECT.
AWESOME AND QUIRKS ARE CONCERNED
I I I DON'T THINK THAT
ELIMINATING A ONE GUN SHOW --
IN ONE LOCATION IS GONNA --
BECAUSE THAT THAT HAPPENED BUT I
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
BIG.
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY OF SO I I SOME NEW SUPPORT
IT BASED ON ON THE FOLLOWING --
WE WENT TO A LONG DRAWN OUT
[inaudible]
ON DISCUSSION.
MEMBERS TO CORP REMINDING ME
ABOUT BUT CANNABIS.
AND ONE OF THE REMAIN LYNCH PINS
TO GETTING IT APPROVED
[inaudible]
AND AUTHORIZED OR LEGALIZE
WHATEVER.
YOU WANT TO CALL IT MEDICAL AND
DON'T USE.
SO DISCUSSION ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL [inaudible]
AND I THINK A LOT OF US VOTED
FOR IT BECAUSE HE WANTED ALLOW
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WHERE CITY
OR COUNTY. TO MAKE THE DECISION.
ARM WHAT GOES ON INNER CITY.
I'M HEARING FROM YOU THAT BOTH
THE LOCAL ENTITIES --
WANT TO PROHIBIT --
MEANS A LOT EXPECTS FREMONT FROM
LOS ANGELES THE CONVENTION
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES HIS OWN.
BY CITY LOS ANGELES AND I DON'T
BELIEVE I'LL DOUBLE CHECK.
THAT.
AND I PROBABLY WILL GET
CORRECTED IF I'M WRONG --
BUT WE'LL HAVE A WHOLE LOT A GUN
SHOWS IF I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
IT.
AND IF WE DON'T IS BECAUSE THE
CITY COUNCIL ITS DECIDED.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY --
GUN SHOOTS GUN SHOWS IF WE
DIDN'T PASS I'M PRETTY SURE.
BY BE SPEAKING NOW THE MACE THEY
MAY STOP IT IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
A THAT AND I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO LISTEN TO
THE LOCAL PEOPLE THIS IS A
UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE THE STATE
OWNED SOMETHING.
THAT IS IN THE LOCAL AREA EVEN
THOUGH I WE ALSO HAVE
[inaudible]
THE THE COLISEUM IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH IS A ACT DISTRICT ALSO AND
I DON'T THINK WE DO HAVE A LARGE.
PUBLIC WILL EVER HAVE A LARGE
GUN SHOW IN THE COLISEUM.
OF SO WITH THAT NAM I'M URGING
AN AYE VOTE BASED ON WHAT
[inaudible]
LOCAL INDIVIDUALS WHAT.
THEN TO HAVE A NICK IN THERE IN
AREA.
OF YES DOES.
THIS I'D FOR ME IS MORE OF LOCAL
CONTROL.
AND WE ACTUALLY SHE BE CONCERNED
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE AND DECIDE
NATURE AND I THINK THE
OPPOSITION HAS A GOOD POINT THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON SCHOOL SAFETY IT'S SAFETY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND NOT STOP ON
THAT AND DISS SO.
THIS THIS IS REALLY ABOUT FOR ME
A LOCAL CONTROL WITH THAT
CULTURAL.
ON S. B. TO TWENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO BE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NOCAUTEADO GALILEO AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT BOATING SANTIAGO.
THE BILL IS ON CALL [inaudible]
IF YOU.
I MISSED HIM I'M BEING SUMMONED
TO THE SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEE
ABOUT THE SHUTDOWN SO COULD I
PRESENT MY SECOND BILL.
AFTER OTHER BILLS --
OR IT IS THE LAST ONE IS.
IF YOU.
I THINK WE BUILD THIS QUICKLY
OKAY GO [inaudible]
I'M.
MOVE THE BELL SECOND.
YOU HAVE THE VOTES YOU HAD NO GO.
I HAVE I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN US I'M MAKING SURE
PROTECTING THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
TRANSGENDER INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS RIGHT NOW WHO ARE
SOMETIMES.
PLACED IN --
ISOLATION AND NOT DUE TO THEIR
OWN BEHAVIOR.
BUT FOR THEIR OWN PROTECTION
BECAUSE WE ARE MISS CLASSIFYING
A PRISONERS AND HOUSING THEM
INCORRECTLY WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
ACCESS TO SERVICES AUDIT THEY
ARE TREATED WITH RESPECT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU HAVE A FIRST AND SECOND VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE I WAS GONNA SAY MORE BUT
I WILL NOT WE THANK SENATOR
WIENER FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD --
I'LL ALSO STATE THE CO
SPONSORSHIP OF BLAMES ILLEGAL
WHO IS NOT ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP THANK YOU.
YES.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY LEAVE
DENSMORE AND I'M THE LEGAL
DIRECTOR.
AT THE TRANSGENDER GENDER
VARIANT IN A SEX JUSTICE PROJECT
AND WE'RE ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE PERFECT.
ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT NAME UP
ORGANIZATION NATASHA MINSKER A
SO YOU OF CALIFORNIA ALSO A CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
JERRY DOYLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONGRESS THE CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND SUPPORT.
ERIC ANDERSON FROM THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
SUPPORT.
WOODS IRVINE WITH THE
TRANSGENDER CHEN EVANDER SEX
JUSTICE PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE YORK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH TRIBE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
SPEC WE IN OPPOSITION --
WE CERTAINLY ARE VERY SENSITIVE
AND UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY IN
OUR AYE JAIL POPULATION.
ON HOWEVER WE WILL BE --
MESS OPPOSED TO SPACE
[inaudible]
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
IN OUR FACILITIES --
AYE WE WE HAVE NO WAY A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER HAS NO WAY
OF KNOWING.
OF KNOWING HOW TO ADDRESS AN
INMATE ON WHAT THEY'RE PRO AND
PREFERENCES --
UNDER PRONOUN ON IT MIGHT BE ON
INTAKE YOU MIGHT BE EASY --
TO FORD IN MAKES A I WOULD LIKE
TO BE REFERRED TO AS A HE SHE OR
DAY BUT ONCE THAT INMATE IS
PLACE ANY HAVE QUESTIONABLE --
OFFICERS WHO ARE MOVING FROM
UNIT TO UNIT OR MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT DAY TODAY AND THE
MIGHT INADVERTENTLY A MISTAKE
HERE AND REFER TO THAT INMATE --
BY IT DIFFERENT PRONOUN AND THAT
MIGHT LEAD TO LITIGATION FROM
THE IN MAY SAYING HEY YOU --
DID THIS ON PURPOSE OR
INTENTIONALLY WHEN IN FACT THAT
WAS NOT THE CASE SOBRE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND ALSO AS
FAR AS THE HOUSING GOES AGAIN.
WE SOMETIMES ISOLATE ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS JUST FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY ON SO AND IT'S VERY HARD
TO AND HAVE A COOKIE CUTTER
APPROACH IS STATEWIDE APPROACH
SAYING EVERY FACILITY NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE FLEXIBLE AND BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE INMATES
WHO ARE IN ISOLATION DEPENDING
ON WHAT THEY NEED.
TO AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
EDUCATION OUT OF THE CATIA OR
TRAINING I'M SO RESPECTFULLY FOR
NOW WE HAVE TO OPPOSE AND ASK
THAT YOU --
VOTE NO ON THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NAME ORGANIZATION OR NO OKAY.
BANK QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SO I KNOW I KNOW TALK
REALLY FAST SO I I DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I DO ASK THAT YOU KNOW
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE REMEDY IS.
IF IF PRONOUNS ARE NOT USED AND
THEN YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
KEEP IT REAL IT'S NOT LIKE YOU
KNOW OUR BAR TAB PRISON
POPULATION IN OUR JAILS ARE LIKE
THE MOST.
PROGRESSIVE AND LIBERAL IN TERMS
OF HOW FOLKS ARE TREATED AND SO
TRAINING --
AND SAFETY CONCERNS IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD HOPE AT
ANOTHER TIME WHEN YOU HAVE TIME
YOU COULD ADDRESS --
YES SO I AM IN TERMS OF I
REMEMBER AS A BILL DOES NOT
CONTAIN A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION --
BUT SOMEONE CAN FILE A GRIEVANCE
OF WITHIN THE WITHIN THE SYSTEM
AND YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE A LONG
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER THERE
SHOULD BE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION EVERYONE HAS THEIR
OPINION BUT I WE DON'T GO IN
THAT DIRECTION.
HOT THERE ARE THIS IS ONE PIECE
OF A BROADER ISSUE --
WITH --
TRANS AM CAR THOSE WHO
[inaudible]
ARE --
TREATED.
VERY POORLY I'M NOT AT ALL
SITUATION BUT IN MANY SITUATIONS
ARE WHO ARE NOT THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY CAUSED BY.
PARTICULARLY TRANS WOMEN WHO ARE
BEING CLASSIFIED AND HOW THOSE --
WITH MEN AND SO THEY ARE THERE
FOR AT SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
ASSAULT SEXUAL SAW AND SO THEM
PLACED IN ISOLATION.
I YOU KNOW QUOTE UNQUOTE FOR
THEIR OWN PROTECTION WHICH MAY
LEAD TO THIS ISSUE OF BEING
DEPRIVED OF SERVICES.
LAW SO THERE IS A BROADER WORK
HAPPENING THAT WE INTEND --
TO YOUR WERE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH HOPE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS START ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE BROADER --
ISSUES BUT THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM LONGSTANDING WINE AND
AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS A IN A
BROADER WAY AS WELL. TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU I TAKE DAYS YOUR
CLOTHES MEN'S TERRY.
CALLED WORLD.
JEREC MANY AND I S. B. NINE
NINETY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE DENSER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARDIO CARDIO I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES BETTER MUCH
CONSIDER [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
LACKEY NOTED NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
SENATE HUESO.
S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY ITEM NUMBER.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS YEAH YOU'RE.
THE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU SIR.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
SIXTY THIS IS.
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE SECURITY
IN THE ENJOYMENT OF GAMING
FACILITY PATRONS AND EMPLOYEES
STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE WITH HER STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTE --
TRESPASSING.
AT GAMING FACILITIES IS THE
CONTINUED PROBLEM AND POSES.
A SERIOUS THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
ONLY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE A
PUBLIC THREAT ARE ISSUED AN
ORDER OF EXCLUSION.
SUCH ACTIVITY INCLUDES
INTOXICATION COUNTERFEITING
HARASSMENT THEFT AND OTHERS.
IN THAT CATEGORY.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S A PUBLIC
LAW TWO EIGHTY STATE.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GIVES A STATE
AUTHORITY.
THAT ITS TO SCRATCH AT THE
DISCRETION OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO ENFORCE THE
EXCLUSION ORDERS ORIGINATING
WITH THEN [inaudible]
TRIBAL LANDS --
THAT AND THIS EXTENDS TO THE
TRIBAL GAMING EX.
ESTABLISHMENT IT'S UP TO STATE
LAW.
WHETHER TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN.
UP HOLD --
LAWS WITHIN.
TRIBAL LANDS SO THIS BILL
ACCORDING TO THAT SPECIFIC
POLICY IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
TO ENSURE.
THAT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS CAN WORK
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES TO UPHOLD THE LAW.
WE ALREADY GET HAVE OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS US SPECIFIC
LETTER OF THE LAW AUTHORITY TO
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENFORCE EXCLUSION ORDERS.
AND THIS BILL IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT CHU CHU ENFORCE
EXCLUSION ORDERS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE SOME.
ALONG FORSMAN AGENCIES IN SOME
COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
THAT ALREADY --
ENFORCE EXCLUSION ORDERS BUT
THAT IS KIND OF A BIGGER AREA
AND THE LAW THAT POTENTIALLY
EXPOSES.
THESE -- OF
THESE --
AGENCIES TO A CHALLENGE A LEGAL
CHALLENGE TO REALLY CHECK TEST.
WHETHER THE LAW PERMITS THAT
[inaudible]
CURRENTLY.
THE ONLY WAY THE TRIBES HAVE --
TO HAVE THEIR EXCLUSION ORDERS
ENFORCED IS TO GO TO A STATE
COURT.
AND SEEK A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST THE MOST PROBLEMATIC
PERSON.
THIS CAN TAKE.
MONTHS IF NOT YEARS.
BUT IT'S A VERY COSTLY AND
DIFFICULT PROGRAM.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
TRIBES HAVE NECESSARILY.
FOUGHT RELIED ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN --
IF FORCED THEIR EXCLUSION ORDER.
S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY THIS BILL
BEFORE US WOULD CODIFY THE
ABIITY A LOCAL ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO ENFORCE TRIBAL
EXCUSED EXCLUSION ORDERS LIMITED
TO TRIBAL TRIBAL GAMING
FACILITIES.
INDIVIDUALS PLACED ON ON
EXCLUSION LIST WOULD HAVE DUE
PROCESS INCLUDING NOTICE AND A
HEARING BEFORE THE TRIBAL GAMING
COMMISSION.
THIS IS THE THE SAME AUTHORITY
AS I MENTIONED EARLY GIVEN TO
CARD ROOMS AT HORSE RACING
TRACKS.
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SECTIONS ONE NINE EIGHT ZERO ONE
AND ONE NINE NINE FOUR ZERO
TRYING WERE GAVE ME SHOULD BE
TREATED.
NO DIFFERENTLY.
AGAIN IN MANY PARTS OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
TRIBAL.
EXCLUSIONS ARE NOT ENFORCED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS TAKEN THE POSITION THAT THEY
CAN NOT.
THAT THE STATE DOES NOT PROVIDE
THEM THE AUTHORITY TO DO SO AND
THIS BILL WOULD CORRECT THAT AND
REQUIRE THEM.
CHU CHU UP FOLLOW THE LAW.
S. B. WOULD ALIGN ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT PROCESS FOR ENFORCING
ORDERS OF EXCLUSIONS.
ISSUED BY TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY WOULD NOT BE
WEEKEND IN ANY WAY.
IN FACT SB ELEVEN SIXTY WOULD
STRENGTHEN IT BY ALLOWING TRUCK
TRIBAL GAMING AUTHORITIES TO
EXCLUDE DANGEROUS PERSONS AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND WOULD GIVE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY TO FOR
SUCH AN EXCLUSION THIS WOULD BE
EXTENDING A VERY NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT SERVICE.
CHIU TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT
HAVING TO SEEK COURT
[inaudible]
A APPROVAL PRIOR TO A TO THAT
PROCESS.
WE HAVE WITH WITH US TODAY I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE STEVE STALIN.
STALIN'S HE'S --
THE CHAIRMAN OF CIGNA STEVE
HARTLEY TRIBAL ATTORNEY IN
MICHAEL STILL THE ASSISTANT DE.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR SAMUEL
COUNTY -- IF
BUT WHAT THE CHAIRMAN'S A
PERMISSION IF THEY COULD PROVIDE
SOME COMMENTS AS TO WAI THE
SKILLS NEEDED YES TO USUALLY
PROVIDE FIVE MINUTES FOR
EVERYONE TOTALITY SO.
HOW HOW YOU WANT TO BREAK IT UP?
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STEVE STALLINGS ON THE
CHAIRMAN THE CALIFORNIA NATION'S
INDIAN GAMING ASSOCIATION.
NOT A SPONSOR OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
BY WITH OUR THIRTY SIX MEMBERS
ARE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
WE REPRESENT THE LARGEST
REGIONAL ASSOCIATION OF TRIBES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
EDITION TO THE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT HAVE YOU LOOK AT OUR
SUPPORT LESS YOU'LL SEE TWO
MAJOR TRIBAL ASSOCIATIONS IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT REPRESENT ANOTHER THIRTY
TRIBES.
S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY WILL ENHANCE
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
CASINO PATRONS AND OUR EMPLOYEES
STATEWIDE.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WORK HARD TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE OR IS
STRONG SAFETY IN OUR FACILITIES.
FOUND IN OUR GAMING
ESTABLISHMENTS --
ACTUALLY.
THE FOR SOME OF THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HERE THIS MORNING.
HOWEVER SINCE THEY ARE
CALIFORNIA'S A PUBLIC LAW TWO
EIGHTY STATE.
TRIES MUST RELY UPON LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COURTS AFTER
THOSE GUILTY OF TRESPASSING IN
OUR FACILITIES.
CURRENTLY ENFORCEMENTOF
TRESPASS LACKEY STATEWIDE
STANDARD OF FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE FOLLOWING.
NOW THIS CREATES ONE BY ADDING A
TRY WORKS [inaudible]
GOVERNMENT --
TO EXISTING DEFINITIONS OF
CRIMINAL TRESPASS SO WE'RE NOT
CREATING A NEW LAW --
WERE JUST ADDING TRIBES --
AND MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THEY
HAVE THE GUARANTEE THAT OTHER
FACILITIES HAVE NOW FOR THE SAME
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROTECTIONS AS
OTHER CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.-IS A FALLACY TO STATE THIS
AMENDMENT TO THE PENAL CODE IS
NOT NECESSARY.
IF THAT WAS TRUE THE CARD ROOMS
AND RACE TRACKS WOULD HAVE HAD
THEIR HAVE TO HAVE THEIR
AMENDMENT TO THE BUSY
PROFESSIONAL COACH --
IT'S SIMPLY ARE ABOUT PATRON
EMPLOYEE PROTECTION TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ISSUE EXCLUSION
ORDERS WHEN INDIVIDUALS POSE A
RISK TO THE PUBLIC.
OTHER FOR FOR PROFIT GAMING
ESTABLISHMENTS CAN DO THIS
ALREADY.
TRIBAL CASINO PATRONS AND
EMPLOYEES DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTION.
NONSENSE PATRONS ARE ANY CASINO
EMPLOYEES ARE OVERWHELMING FROM
OUTSIDE OUR COMMUNITIES IS A
PROBLEM AFFECTS A WIDE VARIETY
OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS --
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS
GUARANTEES A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND PATRONS EMPLOYEES
CAN HAVE A CLEAR PROCESS FOR
REMOVAL EXCLUSION AND CHARGING
THOSE PERSONS OPPOSE A DANGER.
SO WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT. FOR THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE ARE ANY MAJOR INCIDENTS
TO HAPPEN OUR FACILITIES.
THANK YOU.
MIX.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE
STILL THE W. DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO BEEN
A PROSECUTOR FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS.
ON THE TRIBAL LAYS ON FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF SEND YOUR
COUNTY --
AND I ADVISE HER AND WORK WITH.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ON
TRIBAL GAMING IT NEEDS ARE
PRETTY ISSUES SEND YOU COUNTY IS
THE MOST DRIVE ANY COUNTY THE
WHOLE COUNTRY EIGHTEEN A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND THE MOST INDIAN CASINOS OF
ANY COUNTY IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY
CURRENTLY.
ELEVEN BECAUSE HE WAS ATTRACT
PROBLEM PATRONS THAT'S NO SECRET.
THEY POSE A THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY VIGIL TO CHEAT STEAL
HARASS OTHER PATRONS BECOME
INTOXICATED TRY TO PASS THAT
JACKSON YOU STOLEN CREDIT CARDS.
THERE'S ALSO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROSTITUTION AND DRUG DEALING.
TRIBAL GAMING COMMISSION'S
COMPLACENT PERSONS ON EXCLUDED
HER BAND LIST --
AND KEEP THEM OUT THE CASINO --
STRONG SECURITY AND SURVEILLANCE
AT THE CASINOS LETS THEM
IDENTIFY THESE INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY COME BACK UNDER CALIFORNIA.
TRUSTS PASSED LAWS WHEN THAT
EXCLUDE PERSON COMES BACK IN
ORDER FOR THERE TO BE A TRUST
PASS.
THAT PERSON HAS TO BE INTERFERE
WITH THE BUSINESS AND OTHER
WORDS DOING SOMETHING THEY
SHOULDN'T BE DOING ALL OVER
AGAIN.
AND REFUSED TO LEAVE WHEN ASKED
TO DO SO BY CASINO SECURITY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHY SHOULD THE CASINO PERSONNEL
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THIS EXCLUDED
PERSON WHO'S ALREADY BEEN THERE
BECAUSE A PROBLEM BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM ALL OVER AGAIN --
THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
TRESPASS LA DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS AND PREVENT THIS
REOCCURRING REOCCURRING PROBLEM
ENCOUNTERED ANY CASINOS AS
EXAMPLE JUST LAST WEEK.
WE HAD AN INDIVIDUAL PLACING A
VIDEO CAMERA AND A WOMEN'S
BATHROOM AT ANY CASINO IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
ON A PRIOR OCCASION THIS
INDIVIDUAL HAD BEEN SEEN
HARASSING WOMEN THEY CONCEAL AND
HAD BEEN ESCORTED FROM THE
CASINO AND PLACED ON THE BAND
ARE EXCLUDED LIST BY THE GAMING
COMMISSION.
ON THIS OCCASION CASINO
SURVEILLANCE PICKED THEM UP
AGAIN ANTS CASINO SECURITY
FOLLOWED HIM INTO THE WOMEN'S
RESTROOM WHERE HE WAS HE TRYING
TO CONCEAL THE VIDEO RECORDER
UNDER ONE OF THE STALLS.
Y. TICKETS YOU KNOW SECURITY
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THIS INDIVIDUAL
TO DO THIS ALL OVER AGAIN SB
ELEVEN SIXTY WOULD HAVE.
HELPED US CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE IN
GIVE TRIBAL GAMING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOCAL PROSECUTORS.
THE ABILITY TO EXCLUDE REMOVE
AND PROSECUTE THESE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUSLY
CAUSE A PROBLEM IN THE CASINOS
FROM TRESPASSING AND COMING BACK
AGAIN?
THIS IS THE SAME AUTHORITY GIVEN
A CARD ROOMS A HORSE RACE TRACKS
IN A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION
NINETEEN EIGHTY TO ONE IN.
NINETEEN NINE FORTY CARDROOM
HORSE RICKY HORSE RACE TRACK AMY
COMMISSIONS OR BOARD CAN EXCLUDE.
AYE INDIVIDUALS AND PLACE THEM
ON A LIST IN OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
COMES BACK IN VIOLATION THAT
EXCLUSION ORDER.
THERE'D BE PROSECUTED FOR
CRIMINAL TRESPASS.
TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TRIBAL
PEACE AND SECURITY WORDS IS IN
TROUBLE COURTS ARE UNABLE TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSING CLOSES THE
POLL AND CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW.
A DEAL LACK OF JURISDICTIONAL
AUTHORITY AND THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE
TRIBAL EXCLUSION ORDERS.
IS THE CATCH TWENTY TWO S. B.
ELEVEN SIXTY WOULD CODIFY THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TO EXCLUDE TO ENFORCE TRIBAL
SCREW THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM
GAMING FACILITIES IN FAVOR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
INDIVIDUALS PLACE ON EXCLUSION
LIST WOULD HAVE TO PROCESS
INCLUDING NOTICED IN THE RIGHT
TO A HEARING BEFORE THE TRIBAL
GAMING COMMISSION.
JUST LIKE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
EXCLUDED FROM HORSE RACE TRACKS
IN CARD ROOMS.
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY IS NOT
WEAKENED BY THIS BILL ITS
STRENGTH AND RIGHT NOW THE
TRIBES HAVE TO GO TO STATE COURT
RECEIVED A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE TRIBE LOW
ALONG WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR USE W. TIME.
THANK YOU ASKING FOR SUPPORT --
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECONDS OKAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN BARRY BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF UNITE HERE WE HAVE A
LITTLE SEPARATE ISSUE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL FIRST OF ALL.
WHEN I THANK THE SPONSORS AND
SENATOR HUESO?
BECAUSE THE BILL ALANCES THE
RIGHT OF WORKERS. TO ENGAGE IN
PROTECTED CONCERTED ACTIVITY
UNION RELATED ACTIVITY ON AND TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS THIS
ESTABLISHED.
ON SEE CONSISTENT WITH THE WAY
IT'S DONE IN THE REST OF THE
WORLD -- IN
AMERICA ON TO DEAL WITH THE
LABOR RELATIONS TRAVEL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE IN TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS RULES BUT FOR A
WORKER UNION ORGANIZER WOULD BE
SUBJECTED.
TO ON AN ORDER OF X. EXCLUSION
AND FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT
THE BILL WE THANK.
ARMED WITH TANKS SPONSOR AND THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
BUT THURMOND I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NAME AN ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN DRONE SCENE IS IN THE
APP OF THE NIGHT AUBURN INDIAN
COMEDIAN THE BLUE LAKE RANCHERIA
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MONICA THAT'S WHAT
THE KITANA CRUISE COMPANY ON
BEHALF OF THE VA HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY INDIANS WE DEFINITELY
NEED THE PROTECTION THAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES RUN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
THINK TANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH LOBBY AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GENTLEMAN [inaudible]
YES.
I NEED ALL THREE CHAIRS
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ON
CAROLINE BILL HUNT TRUMP HAPPY
YOUR TODAY HE WENT TO NATION.
ON WE HEAR A TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
AS NOTED BY THE AUTHORED ON THE
FACT SHEET SB ELEVEN SIXTY WAS
INTRODUCED TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT PROCESS. FOR HANDLING
TRIBAL EXCLUSION ORDERS ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS AS INTRODUCED
YOUR TODAY HE WENT TO NATION
FOUND THE STATED PURPOSE OF THE
BILL TO BE LAUDABLE AND IS
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO CLARIFY
A CONFIRM.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS RIGHTS TO
ARREST AND PROSECUTE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ENTER PRIVATE LANDS WITHOUT
TRIBAL CONSENT.
THAT RIGHT IS ONE OF THE MORE
FUNDAMENTAL POWERS OF INDIAN
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT TO EXCLUDE
UNWANTED PERSON FROM THEIR
SOVEREIGN LANDS AND BUSINESSES.
WHILE YOUR CHECK HAS A STRONG
WORKING LIKE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUR TRIBAL COUNCIL
UNDERSTANDS THAT NOT ALL TRIBES
DO AND BELIEVES THAT EMBEDDING
THESE PRINCIPLES IN CALIFORNIA
LAW. TO PROVIDE UNIFORM AND
FORCED IT IS A GOOD IDEA.
WE TAKE EXCEPTION HOWEVER TO AN
AMENDMENT INTRODUCED IN THE BILL
THAT REVERSES THE STATED PURPOSE
OF THE BILL.
ON PAGES TEN STARTING AT LINE
TWENTY NINE THE BILL STATES IN
PERTINENT PART THAT.
IF THE ORDER OF EXCLUSION
PERTAINS TO A LABOR ORGANIZATION.
THE TRIBE SO FIRST OBTAIN A
DECISION FROM THE TRIBAL LABOR
PANEL STATING THAT THE ORDERS OF
EXCLUSION DOES NOT CONFLICT WITH
THE TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE.
IN ESSENCE ESTABLISHING THAT THE
TRIBE MUST FIRST SEEK PERMISSION
FROM A THIRD PARTY IN ACT IN
ORDER TO EXERCISE ITS SOVEREIGN
RIGHT.
IT IS AT NEW ONCE TO YOUR TODAY
HE TAKES EXCEPTION WITH.
INQUIRIES HOW WE STATE LAW CAN
SEEK TO AMEND THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE EMBEDDED IN THE TRIBAL
STATE COMPACTS WHICH WERE
NEGOTIATED BY THAT WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND RATIFIED WITH A TWO
THIRDS VOTE OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND APPROVED BY THE PARTNER OF
INTERIOR.
WHILE THE PREFERRED ACTION WOULD
BE TO RETURN THE BILL TO ITS
ORIGINAL FORM YOUR TODAY WE WEEK
YESTERDAY HE WENT TO NATION HAVE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR.
THAT HAVE THUS FAR BEEN REJECTED.
THE AMENDMENTS EMBRACE THE USE
OF THE TRIBAL.
DIMINISH TRIBAL SOVEREIGN RIGHTS
BY REQUIRING THAT THE TRIBE
CONVINCE A THIRD PARTY THAT THEY
HAVE THE POWER TO PROTECT THEIR
LAND AND PROPERTIES.
THAT TO A MINUTE THE PROS THE
POSTMAN WOULD INSTEAD PUT THE
ONUS ON THE NON TRIBAL ENTITY TO
CONVINCE THE TRIBAL LABOR PANEL.
THAT THE EXCLUSION ORDER WAS
ISSUED A ROBUSTLY AND SOLELY TO
OTHERWISE IS TO STOP OTHERWISE
UNLAWFUL ACTIVITY.
IN ABSENCE OF RETURN THE BILL TO
ITS ORIGINAL FORM WE ASK THAT
YOU ADOPT THESE AMENDMENTS AND
WE MUST CONTINUE TO REMAIN
OPPOSED IN ITS CURRENT FORM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT YES I BROUGHT UP YOU ARE NOT
TAKING TIME HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE BROADBAND OF MISSION INDIANS
WE DO FIND OURSELVES IN AN
UNFORTUNATE AN UNUSUAL POSITION
HERE ON THIS BILL.
IN THE SENSE THAT WE WERE EARLY
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL IN ITS
EARLIER VERSIONS HOWEVER IT TOOK
A WRONG TURN --
AS CAROLINE DESCRIBED WITH
RESPECT TO THIS PROVISION WHERE
YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY REQUIRING A
TRIBE TO SEEK PERMISSION TO TAKE
AN ACTION --
AND I WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT
IT IS AN UNUSUAL STANCE FOR US --
TO TAKEN OPPOSITION POSITION --
AGAINST --
AND AUTHOR THAT WE GENERALLY
VERY MUCH RESPECTS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS THE
CASE IN THIS SITUATION SO AT
THIS TIME WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE --
HOLD THE BILL AND THEN I WOULD
ALSO ADD --
AND THAT AFTER THE BILL WAS
PULLED LAST WEEK WE DID REACH
OUT TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO TRY
TO SEE IF THERE MIGHT BE A
DIFFERENT WAY TO THREAD.
THE NEEDLE --
ON THE LABOR PROVISION NICOLE
AND WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD --
AND CLARIFYING APPROACH AND THAT
WAS ESSENTIALLY I REJECTED OUT
OF HAND --
WITHOUT MUCH DISCUSSION US SO
AGAIN WE REGRET THAT WEARING AN
OPPOSE POSITION AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO STOP THE BILL THAT.
THANK YOU SEPPALA TREAT ON
BEHALF OF PECHANGA BATTLE A
SENIOR MISSION INDIANS --
ECHOING THE REMARKS OF BOTH YOU
KNOW CHEN AND VERONA --
THEIR HUNDRED NINE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OUR SOVEREIGN
NATIONS --
SO NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH PUBLIC LAW TWO EIGHTY BUT
AT THE SAME TIME AS A SOVEREIGN
NATION -- WE
IT'S VERY OBJECTIONABLE TO TO
BOTH PECHANGA AND I THINK QUITE
A FEW OTHER TRIBES.
OUGHT NOT TO SIT DOWN IN THE
CONSULTATION AND MAYBE ONE OF
THE ALL TRIBES MEETINGS TO
DISCUSS HOW THIS AFFECTS US --
THE IDEA OF OF REQUIRING TRIES
TO OBTAIN A DECISION FROM A
THIRD PARTY WHEN WE ARE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
NEGOTIATING WITH THE GOVERNOR --
IS IS NOT RESPECTING SOVEREIGNTY
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HOLD THE BELL WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH.
VIA THE AUTHOR WHO'S BEEN A GOOD
FRIEND INDIAN COUNTRY FOR MANY
YEARS BUT THIS ISN'T COOKED YET.
AND THE PARTIES INVOLVED IN THIS
ARE THE OTHER TRIBES THAT ALSO
NEED TO WAY AND OUT WHO DID
SUPPORT THE BILL BEFORE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY ARE EIGHT ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
GLENDALE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THINK
YOU TO ALL THOSE THAT HAVE
TESTIFIED TODAY INCLUDING THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS --
TO TO OUR SIDE OF THE OF THE
CHAMBER NOW.
YOU KNOW I AM I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
AND TO THE POINT THAT THERE OVER
A HUNDRED NINE SOVEREIGN NATIONS
IN OUR STATE AND ENSURING THAT.
WE S. A LEGISLATIVE BODY ARE NOT
IMPOSING ON WHAT TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY IS INCLUDING BOTH
WITH DECISIONS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS SESSIONS
WITH LABOR WHICH WE WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE UP BUT NOT QUITE SURE
IF -- ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED HAVE ACTUALLY
SAT AT THE TABLE TOGETHER TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND AND TRY TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD I WOULD WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE BUT ALSO ONE
UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPACT THAT THIS HOUSE ON
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND NATIONS
ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND HOW BEST WE CAN DO SOMETHING
THAT IS --
ACCEPTED ON ALL ON ALL LEVELS SO --
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO TO SEE HOW
THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
HAPPENED OR OCCURRED OR WHAT YOU
PLAN ON DOING FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT.
THE THE POSITIONS THAT WERE
TAKEN BEFORE SUCH US SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND NOW IN ITS AMENDED
FORM NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS AND HOW WE
CAN BEST INTERPRET THAT --
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE ONE
PROTECTING WORKERS AND
PROTECTING THOSE SIDE.
LIVE ON ON SOVEREIGN LAND.
BUT THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT WE DO AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY IT'S HELPFUL.
CAN I LETTERS LETTER STATEMENT I
IT WAS OUR BEST CHEST MADE ALL
CAPS ARE.
GO AHEAD.
AND NOT SIMPLY PUT I JUST WANT
TO SAY THIS THIS BILL.
HAS IS IS A CULMINATION OF OF
TECH HAS DECADES OF WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE TRIBE.
ARE.
THEY HAVE WORKED WITH THIS WITH
THE TURN.
FEDERAL LAW AS IT PERTAINS TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS VERY CLEARLY.
MEAN THAT THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE.
AT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
WITHOUT --
STATE APPROVAL MANY.
TRAVEL ACTIVITIES ARE ARE
LIMITED.
AND AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
AREAS WHERE WE WE NEED.
STATE INVOLVEMENT TO CLARIFY THE
LAW OR TO PERMIT.
AN ACTIVITY TO HAPPEN JUST LIKE
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU SIGN A COMPACT
JUST LIKE WHEN.
YOU KNOW I I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH TRIBES --
FOR GOING ON FOURTEEN YEARS NOW.
MAN I I SERVED AT A LOCAL
COMMITTEE.
WHERE ACTION WAS REQUIRED FOR US
TO BE INVOLVED IN PLANNING
AROUND TRIBES MAKING INVESTMENT
TRIBE WHAT ROADWAY?
WATER WAY WE HAVE WE HAVE BILLS
EVERY YEAR THAT RELATE CHIU.
OUT WATER DISTRICT ACCESS TO
WATER HOW WE WE GOVERN OUR YOU
KNOW AROUND.
OUR OUR ACTIVITIES IN ND AROUND
THE RESERVATIONS THERE THERE IS
A YOU KNOW.
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT THE STATE
WORK WITH TRIBES AND MANY AREAS
IN THERE'S A REQUIREMENT TRIES
WORK WITH STATE.
ON MANY AREAS AND THAT REQUIRES
LEGISLATION --
WE HAVE EXPERTS THAT HAVE I
LOOKED INTO THIS AND SAID.
THAT WE NEED THIS TO ACCOMPLISH
OUR ULTIMATE GOAL.
WHEN WE TOOK THAT AMENDMENT THE
SENATE?
AND IT DID IT DIDN'T REGISTER AT
THAT AT THAT LEVEL WHITE RACISTS
ARE HERE IS IS.
UNKNOWN TO ME [inaudible]
BUT AT THE STATE LEVEL WE TOOK
THAT AMENDMENT IT WAS CONSISTENT
WITH ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
ON COMPAQ'S.
AND ARE THERE A <c.green> TRIBES</c>
OPPOSED. TWO AT SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE AND COMPACT ABSOLUTELY
THEY ARE.
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S A IT'S A IT'S
A IT'S NOT A SOVEREIGNTY ISSUE.
IT'S MORE OF A DISAGREEMENT IN
TERMS OF HOW [inaudible]
A THEY SHOULD CONDUCT CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF THEIR THEIR BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES.
AND AND NONE THE LESS THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN A CHALLENGE TO THAT.
OTHER THAN A BALLOT INITIATIVE
BACK AND BACK.
AWHILE BACK THAT THE CHALLENGED.
ARE THOSE BEING ADDED TO THE THE
THE COMPACT WERE OVERTURNED BY
THE PUBLIC.
AND IT WAS.
BUT ACTION THAT REQUIRED AGAIN A
STATE LAW.
SO I THINK FOR THE TRIBES MANY
OF THEM THAT ALREADY HAVE THESE
PROVISIONS IN THE COMPACT THEY
SEE IT WE DON'T SEE THE HARM
BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY.
A STATE LAW.
THIS BASICALLY REITERATES --
THE STATE LAW I THINK FOR IT FOR
THIS BILL ADVANCE WE WE LOOKED
AT AND SAID THERE ISN'T A HARM.
BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY LAW THERE'S
NO REASON THAT ADDING IT TO THIS
PROVISION WOULD CREATE.
A DOES A CREATOR REDUNDANT
REDUNDANCY YES AT US I AGREE
WITH THAT.
BUT DOES THAT CREATE A CONFLICT
NO IT DOESN'T.
SO WE DON'T SEE HARM IN ADDING
THAT.
AND WE NEVER THOUGHT THAT IT
BECOMES AN ISSUE. TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU BECAUSE I MEAN THE
TRIBES BASICALLY.
ARE CONSULTED AND SAID --
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM WE SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD THERE IS A AS YOU
SEE A THREE TRIBES MAYBE.
FOUR ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BUT
THIS IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HUNDRED NINE TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA.
CHAU EVERY TRIED THIS IN
OPPOSITION ACTUALLY HAS.
THIS LABOR RELATIONS POUND THEIR
CURRENT COMPACT.
IT DOESN'T PROTECT EMPLOYEES WHO
COMMIT THESE PETTY CRIMES BUT IT
ONLY REALLY PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NORMALLY GOING THROUGH
THEIR ORGANIZING ACTIVITIES.
SO IT ALLOWS FOR NOTHING MORE
THAT'S ALREADY AGREED TO BUY
THOSE TRIBES IN THEIR COMPACTS.
COME OUT OF THE OF COURSE
[inaudible]
WELL SCUD.
I WAS SO --
THAT TOUCHES UPON SOMEONE I WAS
GONNA ASK AYE AYE PROPS ONE TO
BE OPPOSITION A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO THAT POINT IN
PARTICULAR THIS --
GOES NO FURTHER THAN WHAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE CONTACTS.
YOU I WON'T I'M TICKET TAKE A
STAB AT THAT ON IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S NOT SO
MUCH THE PROCESS IT'S THE ORDER
OF THE PROCESS.
THAT IS AT ISSUE IN TERMS OF IT
WHEN OF THIS CLEARANCE AND
PERMISSION MIGHT BE SOUGHT.
AND PERCENT TO THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL.
SO -- YOU
KNOW FROM AROUND THIS PART --
REACHED OUT TO TRY TO CLARIFY
THAT ANY --
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT INVOLVE A
PRE CLEARANCE ELEMENTS AND THE
AND THIS YOU KNOW UP THERE SOME
VARIATIONS OF THAT OPINION BUT
THIS IS WHY DISCUSSION IS
NECESSARY.
BUT FOR BARONE IS PART WE HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO CLARIFY THAT THE
ONLY --
EXCLUSION ORDERS THAT MIGHT
BECOME UNDER THIS PRE CLEARANCE
BY THE LABOR PANEL --
PROCESS WHITNEY THOSE ACTIONS
THAT ARE CLEARLY --
LABOR RELATED ACTIVITY.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT IS A FAIR
LIMITATION ON THIS SORT OF
PERMISSION OR PRE CLEARANCE UP
PROCESS --
BUT WE WHAT WE WANT TO CLARIFY A
AND WE OFFERED WHAT WE THOUGHT
AND WAS REALLY SORT OF SURGICAL --
FOCUS TO CLARIFYING LANGUAGE --
WAS TO CLARIFY THAT IF THERE ARE
ANY TRULY ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES
THAT GO WELL BEYOND LEGAL --
LABOR ACTIVITIES THEN THAT WOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE PRE
CLEARANCE.
SO THAT'S ONE IDEA AND ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WAS FLOATED BUT
THERE WAS NO MEANINGFUL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT IDEA --
INSTEAD THERE WAS JUST AS SORT
OF AN OUTRIGHT DISMISSAL.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT TOO IF
IF -- STAFF
CAN ADD CASSIN'S LETTER WHICH IS
THE TRIBAL LINES A SOVEREIGN
INDIAN NATIONS WHICH REPRESENTS
THE SOUTHERN NEVADA TRIBES AYE
MEANS THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRIBES.
AND THEY'RE ALSO IN OPPOSITION --
AS WELL AS P. CHUNKS LETTER
OF THEM ON JUST FOR PUT AND SO
IT'S MORE THAN JUST THREE TRIBES
THEIR POSTINGS.
REFORM PASS OUT AND RETURN
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW THE DAHLE CANCELLATIONS
ON EKEUS ACTS AS SORT OF I
THROUGH THE TRIBES IN SUPPORTER
AT DO YOU AGREE.
THAT.
IN OPPOSING A THIRD PARTY IN THE
FORM OF THE THE TRIBAL LABOR
PANEL -- IS.
SOME INTRUSION ON TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY OR DO YOU DISAGREE I
DISAGREE IT'S OUR ARMY SOMETHING
WE WOULD AGREE.
TO AGAIN AMBER OWNERS LETTER
THEY CITE EXAMPLES IN EMPLOYEE
WHO STEALS A PURSE.
THAT EMPLOYEE WOULD BE FIRED FOR
VIOLATION OF OF THAT.
THAT THE COMPANY IS POLICY.
THEY'RE NOT ORGANIZING.
THEY WOULD BE FIRED THAT'S THE
EXAMPLE OF THE BARONE A LADDER
SO YOU HAVE TO CLARIFY AGAIN OF
A PERSON'S.
AN EMPLOYEE WHOSE NORMIE
ORGANIZING.
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD GO TO
REGULATIONS PANEL THAT EMPLOYEE
VIOLATES THEIR TRIBES IN THE
CASINOS POLICIES RELATIVE
DISTILLING A PURSE.
THEY WOULD BE FIRED THERE'S NO
NEED TO GO TO THE LABOR
RELATIONS PANEL MANDATORY.
AND THAT'S LEGAL OPINION YOU
KNOW.
I AT THE RISK OF TOO MUCH OF A
BACK AND FORTH FAMILY AND SHARE
WITH YOUR PERMISSION PERHAPS I
CAN GIVE --
THE OPPOSITION A CHANCE TO
ADDRESS THAT POINT.
WE WE WOULD ARGUE AND OF COURSE
LAWYERS HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS
AND DIFFERENT ANALYSES BUT YOU
KNOW THAT IS THAT IS ALMOST
EXACTLY THE POINT THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE VERY CRYSTAL
CLEAR.
AND WE OFFERED LITERALLY A THREE
OR FOUR WERE CHANGE --
IN THE RELEVANT LANGUAGE I TRY
TO PROVIDE THAT CLARITY AND WE
DO BELIEVE THAT ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
COULD BEAR FRUIT ON THIS POINT
BUT TO DATE WHAT WE'VE RECEIVED
IS -- SORT
OF REJECTIONS VIA A EMAIL
FRANKLY AND I THINK THAT AS PAUL
APPOINTED OUT SORT OF IT MORE
ALL TRIBES APPROACH --
THAT THAT IS --
THAT --
WHERE THERE'S A WILLINGNESS TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION TO ACHIEVE
THIS CLARITY IS WHAT IS REALLY
DESIRED AND NEEDED AT THIS POINT?
OKAY ORDER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
THROUGHPUT CLICK.
OBVIOUSLY BY THIS DISCUSSION
SHOWS THERE'S SOME.
SOME REAL SENSITIVITIES HERE
THAT I BELIEVE STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED THROUGH.
I WILL SUPPORT TODAY BUT IF SOME
OF THOSE SENSITIVITIES CONTINUE
TO BE A CONCERN I MAY CHANGE
THAT SUPPORT [inaudible]
QUESTION.
YOU MAY CLOSE WAS HUESO.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY --
IF YOU KNOW AGAIN THIS THIS --
BILL WAS THOROUGHLY REVIEWED AT
THE SENATE LEVEL AND YOU KNOW WE
WE CAME UP THROUGH.
OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR IT --
YOU KNOW I WE WE TRY TO MAKE
THIS ALL THE LANGUAGE CONSISTENT
WITH CURRENTLY WHAT'S THE
CURRENT STATE LAW.
WHY OTHER PEOPLE HAVE LANGUAGE
THAT'S PERMISSIVE THAT ALLOWS
LAW ENFORCEMENT A STEP AND WE
BASICALLY TOOK THAT?
AND AND INSERTED INTO --
ALLOWING TRIBES TO GET THE SAME
SERVICES.
A AS CALIPHATE MEAN THEY ARE --
SOVEREIGN.
A THEY ARE SOVEREIGN GOVERNMENTS
BUT THEY ALSO ARE CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S THAT
PROVIDE A HUGE BENEFIT TO OUR
STATE.
AND THEY SHOULD BE PROVIDE THE
SAME SERVICES AS AS OTHER
BUSINESSES.
BECAUSE THEY DO MAKE A OF
MEANINGFUL CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
ECONOMY AND TO OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN.
A YOU KNOW SEE SEE THE SENSE IN
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE.
AND SEE THAT IT DOES MAKE SENSE
SEE THAT IT'S CONSISTENT AND SEE
THAT NO ONE WILL BE HARMED BY IT.
ONLY PEOPLE WILL BE HELPED AND
AND THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD BEFORE
WITH THIS BILL LAST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND UP AYE PUBLISHES
LOOK WHEN WHEN BILLS COME OVER
FROM PUBLIC SAFETY TO OUR SIDE
PUBLIC SAFETY. TO TO THE SENATE
SIDE HAVE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THE STEAM CHAIRWOMAN OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IS RIGHT BEHIND YOU --
WHICH WE SOMETIMES SEE
SOMETHING'S.
THAT I DIDN'T SEE THAT SHE
DIDN'T SEE AND AND AND WE WE ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS SO IT'S NOT.
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THE SENATE
DID NOT DO THEIR DUE DILIGENCE
ACTUALLY DO BELIEVE THAT.
AND I WOULD NEVER DISRESPECT.
I CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY BY BY
SAYING THAT ESPECIALLY SINCE
SHE'S IN THE ROOM BUT I HOPE THE
CLERK WILL HELP YOU CLARIFY IT
YES.
I ALSO WANT.
THEY ALSO SAY DO PUT OUT AT NO
UNTIL I GOT MORE INFORMATION
ALLEN THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
YOU AND AND OTHERS WHO CORRECTED
ME ON SOME INFORMATION THAT THAT
WAS WRONG.
INFO ONCE I GOT THAT AND MORE
CLARITY IT BECAME ON THAT'S WHY
WENT TO A NON.
RECOMMENDATION --
AND IT TEARS MY HERE MY ISSUES
OUT IT STARTS WITH THIS WHOLE
NOTION.
OF DEA'S AND LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT
DOING THEIR JOB.
THAT IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE
THEY ARE ENFORCING THE TRUST
PASS LAWS AND IN SOME.
THEY DOING.
TO OF DOING IT OR NOT
[inaudible]
TO THAT.
BOB THIS MEET TO KNOW WHEN.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
THAT CAME IN TODAY BECAUSE WE
HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT AND
THIS IS WHERE I'M GOING WITH A
REALLY GOOD ONE HOUR FORTY FIVE
MINUTE DISCUSSION.
AND I THINK WE ALMOST CAME.
TO A RESOLUTION WOULDN'T COME TO
A RESOLUTION BUT WE GOT REAL
CLOSE TO HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
HOW WE COULD GET PAST.
ENSURING THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL ENFORCE TO TRESPASS LAWS --
DATA ON THE BOOKS NOW ANY
AUTHORITY THAT THEY HAVE NOW IT
DO WE NEED TO TWEAK SOME WORDING --
A FORTUNE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO COME TO COMPLETE THAT
BUT I FELT REALLY GOOD THAT JUST
IN A FORTY FIVE MINUTE
DISCUSSION.
WERE ABLE TO TUNE TO MOVE THE
BALL A LITTLE BIT --
I STILL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT DUE
PROCESS --
WHETHER AYE TO TRIBAL AUTHORITY.
ON THE COUNCIL WAYS AND LABOR
WHETHER IT'S TO WANTED TO GOING
TO DO THE IT DID MAKE A DECISION
WHO BE EXPELLED A HOOT NOT THAT
THAT BOTHERS YOU GONNA KEEP
ASKING.
WHO IS IT AND I GOT SOME CLARITY
ON?
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
BUT I GET BACK TO GET BACK TO LA
FORCE -- BY
AS I SAID IN THE MEETING
SOMEBODY WALKS INTO THE CASINO
HAVE FIRED FIVE ROUNDS OFF WOULD
IT WOULD IT WOULD IT WOULD A GUN.
YOU'RE TELLING ME THEY CAN COME
BACK TOMORROW FIRE FIVE ROUNDS
IS SOMETHING.
SOMETHING LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT
BEEN ARRESTED MORE TO GOING TO
TAKE A MOUNTAIN CATCH AND
RELEASE THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG.
WITH IT IT'S NOT MAKING ANY
SENSE TO ME SOMEBODY'S GOTTA GO
TO JAIL.
AT LEAST FOR A LITTLE WHILE TO A
MAKE BAIL BUT THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER DISCUSSION IT WILL HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
AND I THAT THAT BOTHERS ME. TO
KNOW WHEN THAT THAT THAT'S THE
CASE AND THEN THIS WHOLE PROCESS
[inaudible]
DUE PROCESS AND THE REASON YOU
GO TO THE COURTS.
THIRD PARTY IS SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT.
IT'S NOT PERSONAL.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S DONE
ARBITRARY CAPRICIOUS THAT THAT
THAT IT'S DATA TRIBAL COUNCIL
RULES AND REGULATIONS.
MAYBE SIMILAR BUT WELFARE
DISCUSSION WHETHER NOT IN THE
SAME AS TO STATE COURTS AND
WE'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH AND I
THOUGHT.
DATE DO YOU OFFER.
THAT WERE MADE IN MY OFFICE THAT
WE HAVE MEMBERS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
GO OUT.
AND ACTUALLY VIEW TO COURT AND
SEE HOW THEY ADJUDICATE.
THESE PROBLEMS WOULD WOULD BE
GOOD -- BUT
I GUESS IT'S BACK.
TO YOU KNOW WE NEED MORE TIME.
AND CARD ROOMS [inaudible]
AND RACE TRACKS ARE NOT
SOVEREIGN NATIONS.
SO THE COMPARED TO TO SAY THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME THE REASON
WE'RE HERE IS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT THE SAME THEY'RE NOT.
THE RACE TRACK IS NOT A
SOVEREIGN NATION EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY THINK THEY ARE THEY ARE
NOT A SOVEREIGN NATION.
AND SO WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OF
THAT.
AND SO I I'M GOOD AND NOT VOTE
AND I WOULD HOPE.
THAT OTHER MEMBERS NOT.
VOTE.
LAYOFF TODAY SO THAT.
THEN IT GOES [inaudible] TO
WHERE.
AND I WOULD ASK.
IT DOESN'T PASS BASS
RECONSIDERATION AND THAT WE
FORCE EVERYBODY.
COME TOGETHER BIND BEFORE NEXT
WEEK TO LEASE START IRON SOME OF
THESE OUT TO THE ONLY FILL
HAPPEN NEXT WEEK.
IF IT FAILS TODAY.
IS IS A UPPER DOWN VOTE
[inaudible]
AND UNLESS.
CHAIR CAN SEE SOME PROGRESS
[inaudible]
AND NOT HEY I'VE BEEN IN THE
MIDDLE.
OF SOME BATTLES.
BETWEEN.
TWO VERY POWERFUL ENTITIES.
AND ARE I DON'T RELISH PUTTING
MYSELF.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE MIDDLE.
BUT I SURE DON'T WANNA PUT THE
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
FAMILY.
I SAY THAT AND SO AT AT THIS
POINT I'M HOPING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD AT LEAST.
GIVE THE PARTIES [inaudible]
AND ME.
SOME TIME TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
SOME WAYS WE CAN COME.
TO ON SOME REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
AT LEAST GIVE TO FAILING THAT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER SO IF IT DOES GET OUT
NEXT WEEK WE KNOW IT'S GOING THE
RIGHT PLACE TOWARDS [inaudible]
THE FIRST FLOOR.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING
FOR TODAY FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON TO TO LAYOFF TODAY.
OR DON'T GIVE ME A MOTION.
OR IT'S UP TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
POINT OF CLARIFICATION HOLD ON
PEOPLE WISER TO ME.
MADE A RECOMMENDATION.
COULDN'T SELECT WAS A BOW MOTION
I COULD HOLD IT IN COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
WAIT TO TAKE A VOTE NEXT WEEK.
AND GIVE PARTIES TO COME
TOGETHER.
THAT WAY YOU DON'T HAVE AN UPPER
DOWN NOW ORDER WAITING FOR
MOTION WHICH DIDN'T SEEM LIKE IT
WAS.
THE REAL QUICKLY.
TESTIMONY IT AND WHEREAS WHEN IT
WOULD BE WILL JUST TO TESTIMONY
ONLY.
IF NEXT WEEK.
I WILL TAKE OF WHAT NEXT WEEK.
I THINK OKAY.
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
BUT
HELLO.
HI SINNERS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
HELLO MY FELLOW PUBLIC SAFETY
CHAIRED A VERY PLEASED TO BE
BEFORE YOU OF PAULA AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR KIND
REMARKS EARLIER IN THAT.
THAT BILL THAT YOU JUST HEARD
WAS MENDED AFTER MY COMMITTEE SO
THE OPPOSITION THAT WAS PRESENT
TODAY WAS NOT IN MY COMMITTEE
ANYWAY [inaudible]
ENOUGH SAID [inaudible]
BUT WHAT IF YOU MIND IF I START
WITH S. B. [inaudible]
TEN TWENTY FIVE WE PULL.
YES AGAIN WHEN THE RIGHT
EXCELLENT SO I'M GONNA DO IT
FAST BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO BACK
UP TO ENERGY COMMITTEE.
GOT OF COURSE I WELCOME ANY
DISCUSSION BY WOULD DO IT
QUICKLY SP TEN TWENTY FIVE
RESTORES JUDICIAL DISCRETION FOR
CERTAIN NON VIOLENT DRUG CRIMES.
IN RESEARCH BACKED BY THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION AND OTHERS
HAVE FOUND THAT MANDATORY
MINIMUMS [inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS DRUG CRIMES
DO NOT [inaudible]
REDUCE EITHER [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HOW?
TREATING NEED DIRECTION DIRECTLY
CAN SOMETIMES HAVE BETTER
OUTCOMES SO THIS ALLOWS THE
JUDGE TO FACTOR IN ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WITH THAT.
I'M GOING TO ASK ME WITNESSES TO
PRESENT BRIEFLY AND WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
THE MORNING --
HARLAN GROSSMAN I'M A RETIRED
JUDGE FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY A
RETIRED SIX YEARS AGO AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF JUDICIAL
SERVICE I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR
NINE YEARS BEFORE BECOMING A
JUDGE.
SINCE RETIRING I'VE BEEN ACTIVE
REMAINED ACTIVE INCOME OF
JUSTICE POLICY ADVOCACY.
I'M PRESIDENT THIS MORNING TO
ADVOCATE IN FAVOR OF SENATE BILL
TEN TWENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
REPEAL THE PROBATION AND
ELIGIBILITY AND BART A
SUSPENSION OF SENTENCE
PROVISIONS. FOR CERTAIN
ENUMERATED NON VIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES THEREBY RESTORING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO IMPOSE
THE APPROPRIATE SIZE.
TAILORED TO THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH DEFENDANT
THAT COMES BEFORE THE COURT.
RESTRICTIONS ON JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN SENTENCING DO NOT
SERVE AS A DETERRENT TO CRIME
RATHER THEY ONLY MOVED THE BILL.
AND I WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF RESTRICTIONS ON JUDICIAL
DISCRETION SOMETHING DO NOT
SERVE AS A DETERRENT TO CRIME
RATHER THEY ONLY SERVE TO LIMIT
THE DISCRETION TO TIE THE HANDS
OF JUDGES INVOLVED IN THE
ADJUDICATION DISPOSITION.
AND RESOLUTION OF THESE CASES IT
MAKES LITTLE SENSE TO LIMIT
JUDICIAL DISCRETION AND THE
SENTENCING OF THESE MATTERS WHEN
JUDGES RETAIN AN EXERCISE OF
DISCRETION A MUCH WEIGHTIER
ISSUES SUCH AS WHETHER TO IMPOSE
THE DEATH PENALTY WHETHER TO
STRIKE A STRIKE CONVICTION.
WHETHER CASE SHOULD PROCEED IN
JUVENILE COURT TO BE TRANSFERRED
TO CRIMINAL COURT.
WHEN IT COMES TO SENTENCING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT HAVE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH?
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES ARE
NOT EFFECTIVE IN ANY WAY
INCLUDING NOT BEING COST
EFFECTIVE.
AND ACTING SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY FIVE WILL PERMIT MORE IF
FISH EFFECTIVE DEFENDANT BASED
SENTENCING AND MORE EFFICIENT
USE OF CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PERHAPS
BEFORE THE NEXT WITNESS I'LL
JUST QUICKLY SAY BE I'M
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
CREATE CONSISTENCY IN PROBATION
ELIGIBILITY AND SO I AM TAKING
NICE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOTTEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VELASCO WIN AND I AM A SENIOR
TRIAL ATTORNEY AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING ASPECTS OF IS
WATCHING --
INDIGENT.
PEOPLE OF COLOR FOR MENTALLY ILL
AND ADDICTED TO DRUGS BE SENT TO
PRISON.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DEEMED UNWORTHY
OF HOPE AND TREATMENT.
I THE CURRENT LAW PREVENTS ME
FROM NEGOTIATING MEANINGFUL
TREATMENT AND INSTEAD I M.
LIMITED BY ASKING FOR AT THE
MOST MITIGATED TERM.
THE MOST COMMON DRUG OFFENSES
THAT I SEE ON A DAILY BASIS
HAPPEN EXPOSURE OF THREE FOUR OR
FIVE YEARS IN STATE PRISON.
SO WHEN I WALK OUT OF COURT WITH
A THREE YEAR STATE PRISON THAT
IS TEAM TO A VICTORY OUR
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IS REQUIRED
FOR JUSTICE THIS IS NOT A
MANDATE IT'S ANOTHER OPTION.
I AM REQUESTING YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY.
GLENN BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT NAME AND ORGANIZATION
HOW TERESA CHO ACT BE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARCO GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
EMILY CHILD --
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
ERIC ANDERSON FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI I'M OCCUPIED LOGICALLY GOING
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CITY WHERE HER HIGH CHAIR THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY CALIFORNIA SPORT.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEN NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHTY YOU MAY CLOSE --
WITHOUT QUESTIONS IN THE DICE
ALL JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
WITH THE AMENDED BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHOEVER.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. TEN TWENTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO CARILLO I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
CONGRADULATIONS [inaudible]
AND NOW.
THE ONE SP.
TWELVE HUNDRED THANK YOU MUCH.
SHARON MEMBERS.
SP TWELVE HUNDRED WHEN I WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY I CARRIED --
AB TEN FOURTEEN WHICH WAS PASSED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW AND THAT
ESTABLISHED CALIFORNIA'S GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER WHICH
IS ALSO KNOWN AS A VIOLENCE RISK
PREVENTION ORDER --
SO WE WERE THE FIRST STATE WHILE
THERE ARE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE.
SUBSEQUENTLY HAVE ENACTED YOU WE
WERE THE FIRST TO CREATE A TOOL
THAT FAMILY MEMBERS COULD USE
WHEN THEY NEW.
THAT SOMEONE I LOVED ONE WAS
THREATENING SELF HARM. TO
THEMSELVES IN OTHER WORDS SELF
HARM OR VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHERS.
THE MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN ISSUE
OF THE ECONOMIST LISTED GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS OR
VIOLENCE RISK PREVENTION ORDERS
AS THEY TURN THEM.
AS ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TOOLS IN SAVING LIVES FROM GUN
VIOLENCE NOW WHAT THIS BILL DOES
YOU MIGHT ASK WHERE WE HAVE ONE
WHAT IT WHAT IS THIS BILL DO.
IT IMPROVES THERE ARE EXISTING
STATUTE BY ELIMINATING THE FEES
FOR ISSUING.
A ORDER WE DO NOT WANT THE COST
TO BE AN OBSTACLE TO SOMEONE
SEEKING A PETITION.
IT ALSO EXPANDS THE G. BUREAU TO
COVER FIRE ARM COMPONENTS NOW I
HAD A LEGITIMATE QUESTION ABOUT
WHY.
BECAUSE IN INDIVIDUAL FIREARM
COMPONENT OBVIOUSLY IT CAN'T
JUST BE AS DEADLY AS A FIREARM
BUT AS WE KNOW FIRE ARMS CAN BE
DISASSEMBLED.
AND UNLESS BE A PERSON --
ARRIVING TO ISSUE THE AND WHAT
IF THEY DO NOT ASK FOR ALL FIRE
EARN COMPONENTS YOU COULD HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THE PERSON HAS
DISASSEMBLED A FIRE ARM.
AND THAT'S THEY'VE NOT RECOVERED
THE FIRE ARMS IN THE PERSON'S
POSSESSION.
SO THAT IS PART OF THE REASON
FOR THAT AMENDMENT.
ADDITIONALLY IT IMPROVES DUE
PROCESS BY REQUIRING A HEARING
FOR THE EMERGENCY GBR ROSE
WITHIN TWENTY ONE DAYS.
SO WE'VE AND RITUALLY DESIGNED
THE STATUE TO RESPECT DUE
PROCESS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BUT
SAW.
OVER TIME THAT WE HAD FAILED TO
REQUIRE THAT HEARING IN THE US
HEARINGS WERE NOT OCCURRING SO
THAT'S THE BILL IN ITS FORM.
ANDA I WOULD LIKE ME WITNESSES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
ALISON AND HER MAN AND ATTORNEY
AT GIFFORD'S LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SP TWELVE
HUNDRED A BILL WE HAVE CO
SPONSORED.
THIS BILL MAKES IMPORTANT AND
RELATIVELY MINOR CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER LAW AND AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED IT WOULD
INSURE THAT INABILITY TO PAY IS
NEVER A BARRIER TO PREVENTING
VIOLENCE.
IT WOULD ALSO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
RESPONDENTS TO ASSEMBLE
FUNCTIONAL FIREARMS BY REQUIRING
THEM TO RELINQUISH PARTS AND
COMPONENTS THAT ARE CLEARLY
DESIGNED AND INTENDED TO BE USED
TO ASSEMBLE.
A FULLY FUNCTIONAL FIREARM THIS
IS NOT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SPRINGS HERE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT UNFINISHED FRAMES AND
RECEIVERS.
THIRD IT WOULD MAKE IT HARDER
FOR PERSON TO USE A FIRE ARM
ILLEGALLY BY REQUIRING
RESPONDENTS TO RELINQUISH
MAGAZINES.
AND IT WOULD ALSO IN SHORT THAT
A ONE YEAR HEARING IT'S SAD
WITHIN TWENTY ONE DAYS OF A
COURT ISSUING A TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY G. VERO OBTAINED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AS IS ALREADY THE PROCESS FOR EX
PARTE ORDERS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO KNOW
THAT RESPONDED HAS OR HAS NOT
RELINQUISHED FIREARMS.
BECAUSE THESE FIXES TO THE G.
VERO STATUTE ARE MODEST
REASONABLE AND INTENDED TO MAKE
THE ORDERS MORE EFFECTIVE I URGE
YOU TO VOTE I GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MARISSA MAKE SHOWN AND I
WORK AT THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
SKINNER --
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK WE
PROBABLY SUPPORT --
AND AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT ARE IN AS SPEECH I MERELY
BECAUSE LARGE PART OF MY WORK
NOW IS --
HELPING OBTAIN THESE G. BARROWS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IN THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS THERE'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL EXAMPLES OF
THE UTILITY OF THIS TOOL --
THE EXAMPLES THAT WE'VE SEEN
HAVE BEEN A MENTALLY ILL SON
WHO'S PROLIFERATING WEAPONS
WHOSE PROACTIVE PARENTS WERE
ABLE -- TO
GET LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HELP STEP
IN AND WERE IT NOT FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS THERE ARE SOME MAJOR
OBSTACLES FOR US THAT'S HAD.
TO FIX THAT'S IN HERE THAT WERE
SO THRILLED ABOUT IS REQUIRING
AND ACTUALLY TRIGGERING A ONE
YEAR HEARING WHEN YOU APPLY FOR
A TEMPORARY ORDER.
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A MAJOR
OBSTACLE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO
HAVE IT TNCS TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
ORDERS AND THEN DIDN'T GET AN
AUTOMATIC HEARING AND THAT'S
BEEN A PROBLEM FOR US IN OUR
JURISDICTION IN SEVERAL.
OF FAIRLY HIGH PROFILE CASES
THAT I'VE EXPERIENCED --
AND THEN WE ARE ALSO VERY
THRILLED TO SEE THE COMPONENT
PARTS AMENDMENT --
MORE FIX TO THIS LAW BECAUSE
THAT AND IN --
SEVERAL OF THE GDR OWES THAT
WE'VE DONE IN OUR JURISDICTION
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS THERE
HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY TONS OF
THESE COMPONENT PARTS LOWERS
UPPERS UNASSEMBLED FIREARMS THAT
WHEN WE'VE GONE AND CITIES ON
HIGH RISK SITUATIONS.
HAD WE NOT HAD THIS FIX IN THE
LAW THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IT WOULD
HAVE LEFT BEHIND --
FIRE ARM THAT --
THIS IS A VERY COMMON THERE ARE
THAT WILL HELP US ON ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY SO I WE AGREE WITH
ALL OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
IN IN PRACTICAL.
USE THINK THAT THEY WILL HELP
PREVENT FUTURE VIOLENCE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AMANDA WILCOXSON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
WE ARE ALSO CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND URGE DRIVE VOTE.
CALVIN QUICK ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA STUDENT ACTIVISTS IN
SUPPORT.
EDU ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I NEED TO SEE
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS AND
MADAM CHAIR --
FIRST OF ALL WITH THEM.
WE THINK IT'S A VERY POSITIVE
THING THAT THAT YOU'VE DONE IN
IN THIS BILL.
TO TIM MAKE SURE THAT DUE
PROCESS IS AT THE FRONT END.
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT IS A TENANT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY --
OF OF OF REALLY TRUE GOOD
JUSTICE IN AMERICA AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE DO WANT TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
OF CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH
WITH WITH THE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL.
THE THE FIRST OF ALL IT DOESN'T
SAY THE DEFINITIONS THAT ARE
USED LEGISLATIVELY WITH REGARD
TO WHAT CONSTITUTES A GUN PART --
IS OPEN TO MASSIVE --
INTERPRETATION AND IT IN REALITY
IF THEY HAD TRIGGERS BARRELS
[inaudible]
STOCKS.
GRIPS ALL OF THOSE THINGS THERE.
UNLESS THEY HAD THAT PORTION
THAT IS THE FIRE ARM ITSELF --
IT IS ALL OF THOSE THINGS COULD
NEVER BECOME A GUN [inaudible]
NOW.
SO EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
KNOWS THAT A RECEIVER WEATHER
STRIP OR FULLY ASSEMBLED INTO
THE GUN IS IS THE GUN AND IS THE
CRITICAL PART. TO MAKE A GUN SO --
HE IS.
THE DEFINITION YOU KNOW IF
SOMEBODY SEES A TRIGGER GROUP
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT COULD GO INTO
NAY ARE FIFTEEN OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT OR A BOLT ACTION RIFLE.
CLEARLY IT'S A TRICKLE GROUP
CRADLED CLEARLY IT'S A PART OF A
GUN BUT I COULD NEVER BECOME A
GUN OR BE USED.
AS SUCH THE OTHER CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IS WITH THE THAT THE GBR
ROSE AND WE'VE DONE A LITTLE BIT
OF RESEARCH TO FIND THAT.
THERE BEEN UP APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED EUROS THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY.
AND SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE AS FAR AS THE THE ABUSE OF
PEOPLE FILING THEM ALICIA SALI.
ARE HAVE NOT OCCURRED.
BUT THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT.
PUTTING OUR ATTENTION AND AND
FOCUS ON THE GB RO IT'S IT YOU
GO ON YOU SAY OKAY.
YOU WERE A DANGER TO YOURSELF OR
OTHERS AND A FAMILY MEMBER OR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND IN
REALITY.
ANYBODY CAN ASK A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO REQUESTED
UV RO.
IT'S GRANTED AND THEY THEY GET
THEY LOSE THEIR GUNS THAT YEAH
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS ARE
GONNA THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR
GUNS [inaudible]
BUT THEN.
NOTHING ELSE HAPPENS.
IF YOU'RE DANGER TO YOURSELF FOR
OTHERS YOU JUST GO OUT THERE AND
NOTHING IN THE LAW PREVENTS YOU
FROM.
BORROWING A GUN OR YOU CAN BREAK
THE LAW AND STEAL A GUN OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHERE IS WE
BELIEVE THAT THEIR EXISTING
PROCEDURES AND IN STATE LAW
ALREADY IN PLACE --
IN IN PLACE THAT WILL --
ACTUALLY HAVE PROVISIONS.
THAT CHECK TO SEE IF THESE
PEOPLE REALLY DO NEED EMOTIONAL
HELP AND THEM HAVE THEM.
RECEIVE THAT HELP THAT TO US%
MAKE SENSE BUT JUST SAYING NO
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE YOUR GUN
RIGHTS BECAUSE WE THINK YOU'RE
DANGER TO YOURSELF OR OTHERS GO
OFTEN.
MAKE PEACE OR DO YOU CHANGE YOUR
MIND SOMEONE WE DON'T THINK IS A
IS IS IS A GOOD WAY OF OF
STOPPING.
PEOPLE FROM COMMITTING NON
VIOLENT ACTS FOR THOSE REASONS
DOES CALIFORNIA.
WITH APPRECIATION FOR THE THE
THE ISSUES THAT ARE DISCUSSED
WERE POSTED THANK YOU MISTER MR
DELUDE.
IS A MIXTURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRADLE IS ABOUT THE
FIRES POLICY COALITION --
JUST TO START OFF WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE WAY IN WHICH GOODBYES
RESTRAINING ORDERS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN THE PROCESS IN
THIS BILL ONCE AGAIN WE BELIEVE
DOES NOT INCLUDE DUE PROCESS.
DUE PROCESS AFTER YOU'VE LOST
YOUR RIGHTS IS NOT DUE PROCESS
TIMING IS A KEY COMPONENT TO DUE
PROCESS AYE AND WE BELIEVE THAT --
SO SO THE CONCEPT IN GENERAL WE
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH WE NOW IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE WHERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIREARM PARTS --
ONCE AGAIN HE BILL THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY BY ONE OF THE FOLKS
TEST VOTING TESTIFYING IN FAVOR
THAT THERE CLEARLY SPEAKING TO
UNFINISHED RECEIVERS.
I DON'T SEE THAT LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL I JUST SEE CLEARLY
IDENTIFIABLE AND THE QUESTION IS
CLEARLY IDENTIFIABLE TO WHO.
YOU SOMEONE WHO KNOWS AND
UNDERSTANDS WHAT A FIRE ARM
LOOKS LIKE WHAT FIRE ON PARTS
ARE OR TO SOMEONE WHO MAYBE
THINKS THEY DO.
I'VE I'VE COME IN HERE AND
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
BRINGING VARIOUS FIREARM PARTS
WALKING THROUGH --
WALKING THROUGH THE THE
SERGEANTS WITH THINGS ARE
CLEARLY FIREARM PARTS JIMMY BUT
CLEARLY THEY WEREN'T FIREARM
PARTS TO THEM BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
I WAS HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
TESTIFYING.
SHARING THESE WITH YOU OF THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT ARE NOT
CLEARLY IDENTIFIABLE AS FIREARM
PARTS SUCH AS THE 0% LOWER THAN
I PRESENTED A TWO YEARS AGO IN
THIS PARTICULAR COMMITTEE.
ONCE AGAIN. TO KNOW WHAT OUT TO
OTHER PEOPLE TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE EXPERIENCE KNOWING ABOUT
FIREARMS THAT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A FIRE ON PART BUT I RECOGNIZE
IT IS HAVING A CNC MACHINE.
THAT CAN BE TURNED INTO A
FIREARM.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I THAT WE
HAVE QUITE FRANKLY HAS TO DO
WITH -- YOU
KNOW DE DE ONCE AGAIN THE
RANDOMNESS OF OKAY SO HOW WE
GONNA DECIDE WHICH PARTS ARE
LEGITIMATELY GOING TO BE GOING
TO TRIGGER --
THAT THE A VIOLATION OF THE G.
V. RO.
A OFTENTIMES PEOPLE WHO WON'T
FIRE.
MAYBE I DO WANT TO CHANGE OUT.
TRIGGER ON MY ON MY FIREARM
BECAUSE I WANT SOMETHING THAT'S
EITHER SAFER OR BETTER A THAT
WOULD THAT WORKS BETTER SO NOW I
GET RID AYE AYE AYE AYE SWITCH
OUT THE TRIGGER.
AYE MAYBE LEAVE IT SITTING ON MY
WORK BENCH THOSE GEV RO SOMEONE
COMES IN THEY TAKE ALL MY
FIREARMS.
BUT I STILL HAVE THE TRIGGER IN
A DRAWER IN MY IN MY AREA IN MY
WORK BENCH HAVE I NOW VIOLATED
THIS GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER -- I
JUST THINK THAT THAT THAT HAVING
PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW OR
UNDERSTAND FIREARMS --
RIGHT FIREARM BILLS AND TRY --
TO AND TRY TO PROVIDE
DEFINITIONS IS A IS DANGEROUS
AND POTENTIALLY PUTS PUTS THE
RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
ARE IN JEOPARDY IN IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
ANY.
ANY MALES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YEAH.
DODD WHERE I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE FOR
DVR OWES AND I THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT PART OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING.
ALL WE CAN TO PREVENT ANY KIND
OF FOR CIRCUMSTANCES BUT AND THE
THIS PARTS AND COMPONENTS THING
IS FAIRLY --
HARD TO REALLY WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND AND TO REALLY MAKE A
DISTINCTIVE I KNOW WHAT THE
INTENT IS.
BUT THE APPLICATION IS ALSO BUT
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND SO I KNOW THAT DIDN'T WE'VE.
KIND OF PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER
KINDA LOOKING TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFYING.
AND AS A SUGGESTION SIXTEEN FIVE
TWENTY OF THE PENAL CODE SECTION
G..
OF THE LANGUAGE THERE.
IT HELPS UNDERSTAND LITTLE BIT
MORE WHEN IT DEFINES A FIREARM
AND SAYS FIREARM INCLUDES THE
UNFINISHED FRAME.
OR RECEIVER OF A WEAPON THAT CAN
READILY BE CONVERTED INTO THE
FUNCTIONAL.
CONDITION OF A FINISHED FRAME OR
RECEIVER.
THAT WOULD BE MORE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF THEY LOOK QUESTIONS.
YES TO SKINNER MEGAN.
YOU ANSWERS QUESTION YOUR
CLOTHES.
AND APPRECIATED TO WOULD YOU
LIKE NICKERSON.
OKAY I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
WE IT'S MY UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
BILL IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL TODAY
WOULD GO TO THE PROPS COMMITTEE
AND I'M CERTAINLY WILLING TO
LOOK AT THAT PENAL CODE SECTION
THAT YOU REFERRED REFERENCED --
BECAUSE CERTAINLY THAT IS OUR
INTENTION. TO FOR THE INCLUSION
OF THE FIREARM COMPONENTS.
AND IT WILL A PART LEAD I WAS --
INCLUDED ON THE RECOMMENDATION
OF RDAS.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN THAT.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT ASKING
THE FULL QUESTION.
IT LEAVING AN AFFECT THE ABILITY
FOR THE PERSON WHOM THEY ARE
ASSURING ORDER TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE MATERIALS THAT
COULD ALLOW THEM TO ASSEMBLY
WEAPON.
SO I AM MORE THAN HAPPY TO LOOK
AT THAT PENAL CODE SECTION.
AND I'M SURE THE OTHER EXPERTS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
ASSIST ME IN THE ACCU FIRST LAW
CENTER TO SEE IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE --
POTENTIAL AMENDMENT THAT MIGHT
WORK FOR PROBES [inaudible]
IF YOU.
AND WITH THAT EMOTION.
TECH OKAY.
MOVED YEAH WE DID WE DID.
I CHERISH RECOMMEND I CALL VOTE
ROLE.
S. B. TWELVE HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY DICAPRIO.
CARILLO I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES GRADUATION
THINKS FOR ME [inaudible]
AND NOW.
WE WILL NOW GO THROUGH ALL
MEASURES AND VOTE.
ON THE ON CALL ITEMS AND VOTE
EDITIONS <c.green> CHAPTERS.</c>
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL SP TO TWENTY ONE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I DON'T HAVE TO S. B. TWENTY
FIVE WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE SIXTY
ON CONSENT.
S. B. [inaudible]
NINE NINETY SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I AM NUMBER FIVE S. B. TEN TEN
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR WILK CUDDLY YOUR
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP TEN TWENTY
FIVE KILEY.
KILEY NO SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T NUMBER EIGHT S. B.
ELEVEN HUNDRED PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE THAT SB ELEVEN
SIXTY WITH TESTIMONY ONLY.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX KILEY.
KILEY NO SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KAMLAGER-DOVE
AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM TWELVE SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT WITHOUT CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SP TWELVE
HUNDRED HAS JUST BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM FOURTEEN S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
SIX WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
I DON'T A FIFTEEN S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
FEDERAL AYE.
ITEMS SIXTEEN S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE THIS MEASURE WITH
PHONE CALL [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AS B. FORTINO
NINE GALILEO.
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR WITHOUT CONSENT.
THIS INCLUDES TO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING BACK